okay thank you so very much and God
bless each and every one of you I'm just
kind of looking at the audience here and
this is every man's dream 90% of the
people in here this morning are women
you must be already looking at the
previews of the Super Bowl okay
I want to ask her there any health
professionals in here this morning any
doctors nurses Indian chiefs okay good
we appreciate them let's give them a
hand and what you're gonna see is an
adaption of a presentation I gave to the
United Nations
August 7th of this year or a state last
year a couple of months ago and so
you'll notice that there's quite a bit
of stuff from like 20 different
countries because one of the United
Nations to understand that what what I'm
sharing is a thing of humanity as
opposed to America alone and so but it
all tells the same story and so we'll
get going and if you would hold the
questions then we'll have plenty of time
for Q&A afterwards and this will be
considerably different from what you've
learned okay everybody who are supposed
to be ok here we go the thing that makes
me different is that I have a degree in
agriculture I have a degree in
veterinary medicine I'm a compared to
pathologist where I do autopsies and
animals and people and I've been a
primary care physician as a nature panic
physician licensed in Oregon in
California since 1978 so some of the
stuff you're appreciated for the United
Nations someone go fairly fast and I
also received the Lifetime Achievement
Award there in natural medicine
philanthropy very proud of that now how
many of you raise your hand if you ever
heard the CD audio cassette tape or the
book dead doctors don't lie
okay good a few only about 1% 2% we've
sold 350 million copies of the CD 10
million copies of the book and I'm
telling you that not to brag because I
want you to be under
the perspective where we're coming from
Michael Jackson's Thriller his
bestseller he sold 72 million the Bible
has sold trillions right hmm and so
we're putting things in perspective
why dead doctors don't lie because the
average lifespan according to their own
survey the medical system published in
six medical journals in 1999 is
fifty-six God lives forever we need to
listen to God why do we spend so much
time and energy and attention to doctors
whose average lifespan according to
their own survey is fifty-six the
information I'm going to share this
morning is in my newest book one of 14
books epigenetics and it's the number
one bestseller according to amazon.com
in the field of genetics epigenetics and
general medicine in the last couple of
months I'm very very proud of that
okay here's the beginning of the
presentation this is December 1st 2008
Time magazine cover article the sorry
state of American Health we don't have
the best health care system the world
where the most expensive health care
system oral but not the best and what
they said here was that despite
technological advances in medicine
Americans are less healthy than we used
to be and the most terrible part of this
story is that it says that our children
will be the first generation of
Americans who do not live as long as
their parents how many of you heard that
raise your hand okay that's about 10%
our children are not gonna live as long
as us if we continue doing what we're
doing well the reason why I'm on this
crusade and speak 400 times a year
because I'm not prepared to accept that
prediction I'm not gonna just shrug my
shoulders over well that's the way it is
I'm prepared to fight until my dying
breath to save as many kids as we can
okay and because
I believe this is a mission that the
good Lord gave me and I'm gonna carry it
out and this is what we're talking about
grandma died at 92 mom died at night at
64 and daughter and granddaughter died
at 46 this is a word cloud obviously and
you have to appreciate that over the
centuries going back five six seven
thousand years ago the days of the
Pharaohs there's been thousands of
failed medical and scientific theories
every century in the 20th century and
21st century are no different there's
thousands of failed medical theories
let's just look at some of the more
common ones obesity how many heard of
the word obesity okay good we're in the
church so you do have to answer honestly
and the theory for 125 years and obesity
has been that people are overweight and
obese 35 pounds or more of their ideal
weight for their height because they
don't exercise enough and eat too much
that's been the prevailing theory that's
been used in addition to surgeries and
gastric bypass drugs but the basic
concept to lose weight is to eat less
and exercise more and what do we get
that for the last hundred 25 years what
did we get from that theory or number
one or the number one obese nation in
the world we have more fitness centers
people are exercising more than ever
eating less I mean you go on television
those will fix your meals for you all
that kind of stuff and yet we're still
the number one obese nation in the world
it turns out that obesity has nothing to
do with how much exercise and it's only
secondary how much eat because the
symptoms of a deficiency of a class of
nutrients will cause you to have the
munchies if you choose poorly and eat
things that have lots of easy calories
you're going to gain weight if you
choose things to eat that don't have
easy calories in them you won't gain
weight exercise effectively has nothing
to do with your obese or not it's a
deficiency you take the nutrients and it
goes away at the rate of up half a pound
to two pounds a day where the exercise
or not now let's look at alzheimers
disease
Allisyn disease when it was first
recognized 45 years ago never existed
even by another name and certainly not
genetic the big theory originally was
was it was caused by aluminum how do
how many of you heard of the aluminum
theory of Allison disease well that's a
failure turns out that aluminum is an
essential nutrient for a succinate
enzyme required for metabolism your
mitochondria inside your cells so then
if it's not genetic and it's not
aluminum what causes Allison disease as
a simple deficiency disease was caused
by medical doctors who took if you will
a bribe from Procter and Gamble
to demonize cholesterol and saturated
fat to sell another product and the
result of demonizing cholesterol and
saturated fat and cholesterol lowering
drugs is many many diseases which we'll
talk about in a few moments the most
egregious one of course is Allison
disease it's a physician cause disease
easily prevented and easily reversed
we'll talk about that in detail
cardiovascular disease raise your hand
if you've ever heard it has something to
do with with saturated fat and
cholesterol remember your church I ask
it again how many of you heard that
cholesterol and Sharaf and have
something whether you believe it or not
have something to do with cardiovascular
it's better right now it turns out the
congestive heart failure very common
cause a heart death in adults is a
deficiency have a single vitamin we've
known that for 300 years it was
discovered by a Japanese naval surgeon
300 years ago swans by deficiency of a
single vitamin and it's easily reversed
in just a couple of days 5 10 15 20 days
a month at the most very easy to get rid
of you don't have to have a heart
transplant you don't have to be on
medication for 25 years praise God then
cardiomyopathy heart disease the thing
that kills athletes suddenly are people
who drop dead well they're doing hard
physical work is caused by deficiency of
a single mineral I've personally done
1,700 autopsies on kids under the age of
10 that have died of that one big
government project and then there's
coronary heart disease where you have
plugged arteries that doesn't is not
caused by closure on saturated fat
that's caused by inflammation how many
view heard of the inflammation kind of
concept
okay well inflammation causes your
arteries to react and put out scar
tissue to protect themselves from this
irritating like pouring acid through
your veins and arteries
and the scar tissue plugs yours when you
do special stains on the plaque in your
arteries there's no cholesterol in
saturated fat in there it's all scar
tissue it's easily gotten rid of easily
prevented without surgery without
bypasses you may need a stent once
awhile for an emergency sort of thing
and then coronary thrombosis we get a
blood clot in the coronary artery it has
nothing to do with cholesterol saturated
fat it's actually a deficiency of
animega 3 essential fatty acid
deficiency our ratio plum in your diet
of omega-3s sixes and nines and you see
so many omega-3 products advertised on
radio and TV because of this in the
newspapers and that's one of my nine
lawsuits against the FDA in which I
prevailed in all nine cases hypertension
is not a genetic disease even in the
black community it's a simple deficiency
of nutrients easily eliminated very
quickly arthritis is not genetic has
nothing to do with age babies are born
with arthritis it's a combination
deficiency of vitamins and minerals and
then type-2 diabetes has nothing to do
with genetics type-2 diabetes is a
simple deficiency of a single mineral
we've known that for 80 years I actually
back in the 1960s discovered as a type 2
diabetes and crocodiles and alligators
and I was wondering how did a crocodile
from Africa get human genetic disease he
must have been eaten Baptist preachers
that had diabetes in Africa or something
it turns out that this one deficiency
this one mineral universally gives
diabetes to any vertebrate whether
they're a crocodile or a snake or a
hummingbird or a deer or a human being
it doesn't matter again some of this
stuff I had to educate all these
ambassadors so we're gonna flip through
a lot of this stuff witches were burned
at the stake witches are usually
grandmas who are using herbs and chicken
soup to heal people make him feel better
and the medical system didn't like that
and so they would go to churches and say
grandma Ruthie is a witch she's using
witchcraft to cure people who said
church's job to cure people
so the churches of the day would send
out inquisition committees to torture
these poor graham
until they admitted to and confessed to
being a witch and using witchcraft and
then they were rewarded by being burned
at the stake and the doctors are happy
all the way to the bank
the FDA in the medical system their
limit of nutrition as the four food
groups for a long time for about 50
years we used as seven food repear mean
how do you remember the seven food group
pyramid okay well that was too
complicated for the FDA the government
medical doctors so they reduced it to
the four food groups now remember this
is what we're doing and this is why
we're sicker than we've ever been this
is why we're dying younger and younger
and this is why your children will not
live as long as you you cannot get
everything you need from the four food
groups because the nutrition is not in
the food anymore we'll talk about that
in a moment
the original pharmaceuticals for the
doctor would give you something in his
office was homebrew is whiskey and you
know good Kentucky Bourbon and that kind
of stuff one of the big ones was
coca-cola coca-cola before prescriptions
coca-cola was cocaine that's why they
called it coca-cola and in the 1920s it
became a prescription item cocaine for
dentistry primarily in the beginning and
so they had to take it out of the
coca-cola the over-the-counter in the
end the the drugstore stuff they were
pulling out of the little things and the
Tampa goes you called it and today
coca-cola is one of the biggest export
products to the world this is how people
know us Oh coca-cola that's that's the
American thing and then before the drugs
prozac and others for depression doctors
would prescribe cigarettes call for
Philip Mars I'd walk a mile for a camel
and it's always a doctor in his white
coat and a stethoscope he'd walk a mile
for a camel
there's probably wiser average lifespan
is 56 hospitals over charged patients by
a thousand percent they'll charge you
five hundred bucks for a three cent late
Texas examining glove and nobody pays
attention because insurance pays or
Medicare pays when you get the statement
in the mail you just throw it in a
drawer burn it throw in the trash nobody
sits there and goes item by item to see
what you were charged every time doctors
go on strike who work for the hospitals
are on the hospital's
as opposed owning your own clinic every
time doctors go on strike in hospitals
all over the world where's England or
Israel or United States the death rate
goes down that's a fact
you can google it death rate in
hospitals when doctors are on strike
people don't die anymore
this doctor jerry block from tulsa
oklahoma I go there quite often there's
so many churches in Tulsa Oklahoma is
called Tulsa Russa ylim because there's
so many churches there and he was fined
a hundred and five thousand dollars
which is chump change dat him for miss
billing Medicare he would charge people
for things he didn't do he would charge
people for things he did that they
didn't need and one hundred five
thousand dollars was not a big deal for
him it's kind of chump change in him but
when two hundred patients lined up to
sue him for five to ten million dollars
each because they had it cut things off
that they didn't have to have done but
he needed the money he jumped off a
20-story building committed suicide
October of 2015
prescription drug abuse is reaching
crisis proportions right now fifty nine
percent of American adults are on five
or more prescription drugs the medical
system has failed as terribly here and
primarily they'd like to use addictive
drugs such as opioids why do they do
that because you have to come in every
month get your prescription fulfilled
that way they keep getting the office
fees okay
it became such a big story as a cover
story in Time magazine in June of 2015
this is one of my favorite articles a
full page article and had to chop it up
a little bit came out of every 50 2007
full page article in USA Today the title
is a little vanilla for me patient
protect thy self and the line which
appears to be aligned just above patient
protect thy self is really a list of
some of the sources that they got the
information from the Institute of
Medicine the ethics watchdog for the
medical system the journal the American
Medical Association the most prestigious
medical journals certainly in America
maybe the world and then the Center for
Disease Control which is a federal
agency the Traxxas stuff and the figure
I'm gonna give you which came from those
agencies is a yearly figure this is not
a hundred years of accumulated data this
is a yearly figure according to them and
that's in the kind of upper left-hand
corner under medical mistakes it says
each year in America each year in
American medical doctors kill injure and
infect 15 million patients right here in
America alone each year american medical
doctors kill injured infect 15 million
patients each year let's just look at
2006 again this is the Institute of
Medicine - the study it just looked at
decimal point errors where the
prescribing physician actually had some
decimal mistakes are they're fulfilling
pharmacists and made some decimal point
mistakes these types of mistakes yearly
figure are tallied up at one point five
million fatalities and permanent
injuries each year from decimal point
mistakes and prescriptions let's just
look at infections in hospitals each
year just American Hospital this is a
Center for Disease Control the federal
agency the tracks of stuff they said
that there's two million infections each
year from one bug c-diff classroom
difficile which is a human poop bacteria
and they tracked it through hidden
cameras that doctors just don't wash
their hands after they go potty things
that you things that you teach a
three-year-old to do doctors don't wash
your hands after they go potty and
results in two million infections each
year in households now those two million
infections as you look at the second
paragraph on the left-hand column it
says of these two million patients are
infected each year in hospitals 90,000
die
each year 90,000 died from these
infections if doctors simply don't wash
their hands after they go potty I'm
gonna give you a theoretical problem
here
what if North Korea what if Iran what if
Isis were to send over an
intercontinental ballistic missile with
a biological weapon infect large
population centers like Newark New
Jersey Philadelphia what about New York
what about Atlanta what about Dallas
Texas what about LA what about Chicago
in fact two million people with that
biological weapon and killed 90,000 it'd
be war wouldn't it well here's one trade
that does it every year in their office
their workplace they don't even get an
OSHA ticket they get a walk every time
that's because people make the mistake
of loving their doctor more than they
love God
don't you to appreciate that every time
you see something the newspaper that a
certain drug has been recalled because
it's wounding or hurting people or a
device medical device such as the
endoscopes from above and the and the
Columbus Copic examination from below or
hurting people they pull them off the
market the FDA will pull them off the
market well when they withdraw these
things whether it's the drugs or the
medical devices guess what the FT is the
one who approved them they approved him
taking the advice without challenge from
the people who made them there's all
this hanky panky under the table
death rates rising for middle-aged white
Americans because they're all getting on
these opioid drugs from the doctors this
doctor who built four surgeries that
were not performed particularly he said
they people had cancer
he got a hundred and seventy five years
in prison this is from Detroit but I
guarantee he won't spend that much time
there he'll get out in two years medical
guesswork when doctors don't know what
you have they won't say you know I
really don't know I want to give you
another appointment next week for free
and you come in and in the meantime
between now and then I'm going to
contact the University I'm going to
contact CDC and I'll have some answers
for you within a couple of weeks instead
they'll always say you have an
autoimmune disease your body's attacking
itself and I can help your symptoms but
I I can't totally deal with this disease
because your body's attacking a cell or
he might say did your mom or dad have
this because he's looking for genetics
right and did your brother and sisters
have it no no and then he gets desperate
and he'll say does your dog have it
each surgeon United States makes
thousands of errors each year he's
surgeon United States makes thousands of
errors yearly this was first shown in
1990 by Lucien lepay who's a head of the
department of public health at the
Harvard School of Medicine 1990 and he
did it again
in 2014 and you know we're talking about
take out the normal lung leave the
cancers lung in cut off your right leg
when you should have taken your left
cataract out give you a heart
replacement when you just went in there
you just went in there to have a stent
put in how does this happen
well according to Lucien lepay the head
of the department of public health at
Harvard Medical School 1990 in 2014 he
said and he did the study he went and
got blood samples from these doctors
saying hey we're doing a study on
doctors and they just volunteered and
gave their blood on hundreds of them he
found out that 52 percent of the doctors
in emergency rooms and surgical suites
and their private clinics 52% are
intoxicated every day when they go to
work on alcohol street drugs and
prescription drugs we did it again in
2014 got the same answer no what I want
you to do is email your federal and
state representatives your federal and
state senators your governor's your
presidents and ask that doctors have to
breathe into a breathalyzer test before
their key won't work in their office if
they're not sober and they have to have
pee in front of a nurse into a cup
because I don't want to bring their dogs
urine right they have to pee in the cup
and then the nurse will have a test
strip to put in their screen for drugs
and if he passes everything every
morning he has to go to work if he
flunks he goes to jail for three months
and has his license taken away why
should you suffer death and injury I
mean you would they test athletes when
they win a gold medal they test them for
drugs are gonna sakes
cat scams cause cancer one cat scan
gives you the radiation of 500 chest
x-rays even the government says don't
get them there is a a procedure called a
high-resolution ultrasound which will
give you the same information as a cat
scan but the doctor only makes $50 for
the high-resolution ultrasound he makes
$2,500 from a cat scan mammograms are
not prevention one mammogram gives the
radiation of 500 chest x-rays ladies so
your doctor insists that you must have a
mammogram what you do is this doctor
I've been your patient for 10 15 20
years whatever it is and I really
appreciate you as I keep coming to you
and I know you're probably insisting
that I do this mammogram because you're
concerned about my health but I'm
concerned about the safety I've been
reading a lot of things in the papers
and seeing things on TV and hearing on
the radio and that there's a problem
with the safety of mammogram so I want
you to prove to me that it's safe and
then I'll do it if you can prove to me
and save I'm doing the doctor if he's
smart he'll stay well okay how can I
help you how can i what can I do what
question can I answer for you to help
you feel comfortable at the safety of a
mammogram and ladies here's which is
say sir if you'll put your testicles in
that machine
[Applause]
ha
remember I'm quoting you now ladies I am
woman and I guarantee there will never
be another recommendation for mammograms
[Applause]
this is obviously a Canadian story and
it deals with an American story that was
put out in 2011 by the US Department of
Health and Human Services a presidential
cabinet post as supervises this a US
Surgeon General and it became a Canadian
story and what they're saying is that
each month each month in America medical
doctors kill 15,000 seniors over the age
of 65 because they send them in for
unnecessary screening tests and what
they would call minor procedures as a
180,000 year seniors that are killed by
unnecessary testing and procedures
because the doctor needs the income to
pay his bills
now most people didn't read this article
because the headline intimates that this
is a governmental problem u.s. health
care weighs 750 billion dollars here's
here's what's new if the government
wastes a lot of money and so what should
be surprising there but this is not that
what the story said what the story said
was your doctor your primary care
physician your GP actually bills for
things he didn't do like that guy that
went to prison four hundred seventy five
years and he bills for things he did do
to you but you didn't need because he
didn't want to pay back a student loan
he just bills you you pay him he pays
the universe he doesn't have to pay it
back he uses you as an ATM machine at
this point I have to tell you a little
story and you'll see some of this in a
moment I worked a lot with the
african-american in the black community
all over the world since 1991 and
there's reasons for that which I'll get
to in a moment but just before she died
and credit Scott King called me because
I've been working with her son Martin
Luther King the third and with his
weight problem and and diabetes and so
forth and she said to me in in her condo
I spent four hours with her by she and I
alone as I was a blessing what a great
woman and she said to me yes dr. Wallach
I'm dying of cancer the you know the
universities and the cancer doctors have
given up on me I've only got months to
live and it's time for the march from
the Ebenezer Baptist Church to the Kings
Center for dr. King's birthday and I
want to March one last time she says I
don't think I can physically make it and
and she had all kinds of terrible
complications for her her cancer as well
mrs. King would you like me to help you
with your cancer she doesn't know I've
already made up my mind I'm ready to be
with Martin and I really just want to do
this one last March so she shared with
me what her complications were what her
restrictions were we came up with a
program and and praise God she was able
when the time came she was able to
complete that March so we give God all
the credit on that one right
but the beautiful thing out of that four
hours that I spent with credit Scott
King was this I said ma'am I have I have
one question to ask you if I may about
dr. kingship oh please anything I said
well when dr. King knew he'd won the
civil rights movement when he knew
legislation was coming did he kind of
fold his tent say okay it's time to
retire and I can just go back to
preaching to my church or you know what
was his thinking when he won such a
great great thing he said oh that wasn't
the end for him that was just the
beginning
she said the medical system was next
because he knew that the medical system
in the US and this is all in my newest
book which is the bestseller Mitchell's
as you've seen Minh to great detail with
dr. King knew how many of you heard of
the Tuskegee Experiment okay that was
one of the nicest things that the
medical system ever did to black people
compared to all the terrible things that
were done to them and their most of them
are listed in that book of epigenetics
and there was a horrible thing she said
dr. King knew this and he was going
after the medical system next to make
sure that the the black community was
not taken advantage of okay not being
used as an ATM machine not being used as
an experimental animal in 1980 it was
one out of 250,000 kids had autism now
it's one out of 45 how that happened
well there's two reasons number one
there's enormous incentive there's
enormous incentive for a pediatrician to
diagnose a child with autism because the
statistics are over a five year period
with an autistic kid regardless of the
age over a five year period the doctor
will the pediatrician will make two
million dollars so why wouldn't every
kid that comes in have autism secondly
the brain requires 90 essential
nutrients 60 minerals 16 vitamin 12
amino acid 3 fatty acids and our
children don't even have
half a chance to get that anymore when I
was a kid for breakfast we'd have beats
and we have sweet potatoes and we'd have
eggs have steak for breakfast or a
hamburger patty today they'd get fruity
pebbles and apple juice on the way to
the daycare center
this little Latino girl 28 years old was
from a low-income family and so she was
using county facilities for her prenatal
care and when she got pregnant for her
pregnancy monitoring the day came to
have her baby the doctor had been
monitoring her they paged him and he's
playing golf Ian's on the 14th hole and
he said oh this is her first pregnancy
to take a little while keep me informed
and so 45 minutes later they page him
again all this baby's crown his baby's
coming quick got to be here there's no
other doctors here if she needs a
caesarean if the baby needs something
special there's nobody here to do
anything you got to be here doctor we
came in 45 minutes later just as the
baby was crowning and he goes right
through the scrub room didn't wash his
hands cut her arms and legs off then
delivered the baby now he did it six
months later to another woman who had
interrupted his golf game he's still
working at that County Hospital in
Orlando Florida because it's a County
Hospital it's a government house when
were the big Union they can't fire him
I've heard daddy if I was her daddy I'd
have been I'd have been found guilty of
temporary insanity
and that fella would not hurt anybody
else
this is in England this was a delivery
where the mother had a very small pelvic
canal through her pelvis was obvious the
baby's not gonna be able to be delivered
normally and so they had planned in
advance for a c-section and I don't know
why maybe he's intoxicated maybe he's
just in a hurry but he entered his hands
into the birth canal and pulled on the
baby's head and pulled the baby's head
off from the from this from the neck
vertebrae the skin was still there just
holding the head on so he pushes the
baby back in then he does a cesarean
section of his baby was born in this way
well fortunately a nurse reported him
and I had to find out what the follow-up
is there's not a single disease is
caused by genetics the concept of
disease being caused by genetics is an
overreach by the medical system and the
scientific community back in the days of
Darwin back in the early 1800s he knew
that in Scotland where the mother had
read here in the father had read here
all babies had red hair also in Scotland
or Ireland couples that had black hair
maybe out of every ten baby there'd be
one born with red here and they thought
there was hanky-panky going on at the
time right but they kind of realized by
doing animal things in agriculture that
there's messages that both a mother and
father give the baby and there was
hidden messages and they could appear
sometimes in the babies whether it was
an animal or human and then of course
with Gregor Mendel's pea experiments he
was a priest that did this sort of thing
they began to think of genetics then
every time a baby is born with a problem
they say oh it's genetic what turns out
that all birds defects I'm gonna repeat
that all birth defects are caused by
nutritional deficiencies the embryo even
sickle-cell anemia
I'm finding sickle cell anemia and
hummingbirds and deer and antelope I'm
finding sickle cell anemia and white
folks but it's called thalassemia and
white folks cuz you can't have black
jeans and white folks or white jeans and
black folks they give it the same as
these different names
I mean come on you got to protect your
industry right well 1961 on a on a grant
from the National Institutes of Health
actually I take that back that's not
true I'm dancing I'm ahead of myself
here in 1961 I actually ran into the
first mass die-off in America from
pollution 1961 I was a graduate student
I'd already graduated agricultural
school the University of Missouri was
into my third year of veterinary school
and so as a graduate student and I was
taking pathology courses it was December
61 when all the professor's were off in
the graduate students are in charge of
the services and I was in charge of the
services for pathology and it ran into
the first mass now from pollution did
all the chemistry's got it right and
published it and so I was published at
age 21 at with a scientific study in
veterinary journals medical journals and
books
well after graduating veterinary school
Marlin Perkins the old mutual Omaha Wild
Kingdom show on TV I had worked for him
during the summer times as a kid he sent
me to Central and South Africa what is
now Zimbabwe which needs to be Southern
Rhodesia and the Republic of South
Africa back in the 60s and he was 66 67
I was there two years and my job was to
catch Ryan and white rhino because they
were on the on the list where they were
going to be rare and endangered and go
extinct there's only 400 left south of
the Zambezi River and I caught 200 I'm
half of them sent it back to the States
so if you see a white rhino in a zoo or
wild animal park it's either one that I
caught or offsprings are the ones that I
caught so I'm very proud of that we
saved the species now there's 10,000 of
them both in the wild and in captivity
combined so it was a great project after
two years of working on that Perkins
sends me a letter saying he's got this
this grant from the National Institutes
of Health and since I had given him a
copy that paper on the mast down from
pollution he wanted me to be that
pathologist on the project because we're
gonna study pollution and it was called
the center for the biology of natural
systems as the Department of Biology at
Washington University the st. Louis
Botanical Gardens and to make a long
story short this is the director Ron
Perkins was the biologist now as a
pathologist and after ten years I had
done 20,000 autopsies 10 million
chemistry's 10 millions of special
stains and 17,000 some change of those
20,000 autopsies were were 454 species
of zoo animals and then there were 3,000
humans the data from that provided the
information for 75 scientific papers are
published in medical journals and
veterinary journals and chemistry
journals but also the book contained all
the data from these 20,000 autopsies and
ten million chemistry's it's 1,200 pages
it's in the Smithsonian Institute as a
national treasure when they sold them
back in the nineteen late 70s when it
came out it was selling for $140 a piece
which was thought to be a great price
for a book like that because back then a
textbook was 30 bucks or 50 bucks so 140
bucks was just like outrageous they
printed 10,000 copies the top medical
publishing house in the world WB
Saunders and they sold him out in two
weeks 140 bucks apiece well today if you
can get one all beat up on eBay or
Amazon used books you can get one that's
all beat up and dog-eared and underlined
and highlighted and coffee stains all
over it for less than $2,000 you better
get it if you can get one that's still
in the box and wrapped up in the cover
was never opened they're going for
$25,000 each because of the information
it's gonna cost a billion dollars to
redo that study and back then it cost
him 25 million dollars into the study to
be a billion dollars so universities are
prepared to spend twenty-five thousand
dollars for the book so you want to be
looking for him and used book stores and
things him might hit the jackpot all
birth defects again are caused by a
nutritional deficiency the embryos have
nothing to do with genetics the double
helix structure was proposed in 1953 by
James Watson an American on your left
and Francis Crick a British guy on your
right they collaborated and came up with
the proposal that the structure of DNA
was it was a double helix by 2003 to
2011 we'd mapped out the human genome we
knew all the human genes
and they had been placed on various
chromosomes and they attributed certain
diseases to each of the genes on the
chromosomes and 850 biotech companies
are farmed and over a period of 60 years
between 53 and 2013 they have spent has
spent more than I don't know similarly
810 trillion dollars worldwide looking
to find a way to genetically engineer
stuff to replace the bad genes and
people get rid of disease over a 60 year
period they're unable to do this and
what we learned because of my study and
this is why the book is in the
smithsonian institute national treasure
sickle cell anemia is not a genetic
thing I can take a black woman with
sickle cell anemia and a black man with
sickle cell anemia and they have ten
kids and not one of them will have
sickle cell anemia because I'm gonna
give her everything she needs to make
that embryo perfect okay it's an in barn
air metabolism they call it and what it
is and again I'm the guy that discovered
it because I'm seeing these things in
hummingbirds and deer there's supposed
to be a black genetic disease but it's
in all these animals all these
vertebrates non-human it turns out it's
a birth defect of the bone marrow it's
kind of like a cleft palate in the bone
marrow and so when the bone marrow was
farming in the third and seventh week of
pregnancy there wasn't enough for the
right nutrients to farm perfect bone
marrow which makes hemoglobin and so the
hemoglobin in his farm from this defect
is dysfunctional hemoglobin is not
genetic now they didn't have the
knowledge to know back then it wasn't
genetic because the baby was born from
it or with it okay this to them it meant
it was genetic
the same disease and white folks is
thalassemia and then of course another
inborn error metabolism you know this is
not genetic kinetic has a lactose
intolerance when the lactase enzyme
mechanism is being formed in the
pancreas of it and the small intestines
early in pregnancy something's missing
mama doesn't do that properly and so if
you're gonna go to an ice-cream party
and have some fun you need to take a
lactase enzyme capsule so be ready for
all the lactose same thing with type 1
diabetes is not genetic there's supposed
to be 500 thousand per islet of
Langerhans of these beta cells which
manufacture
insolent but and somebody who's a type
one they only have ten not ten thousand
just ten just barely enough cells to
make enough insulin so that a little
baby can be okay but once they hit six
eight ten years old pre pre pubic
they're growing rapidly because the
growth hormones coming out they don't
have enough insulin they and they're
recognized having type 1 diabetes lipid
storage diseases tay-sachs disease all
these things are thought to be genetic
it turns out they're just nothing but a
inborn error of metabolism mom is
missing something is the baby's going
down the assembly line epigenetics is a
current bestselling book the death of
the genetic theory disease transmission
you'll see why witnesses said in a
moment
that's me back in 1977 and black gene
lies this is a book and if I may I'm
gonna take my coat off because I'm
getting cooked by these lights up here
thank you thank you Pastor okay um this
book publication was paid for by pastor
Creflo Dollar from Atlanta Georgia how
many of you heard of him okay good yeah
great gentleman he his wife passed her
caffeine and I was just so happy to see
that the pastor is here at the church's
know him and everybody knows each other
very well any rate back in 1991 I was
introduced to him by Andy Young who ever
worked with a lot from the civil rights
movement the mayor of Atlanta and pastor
United Nations and he told me that that
pastor dollars 11 year old daughter had
a genetic form of asthma that only black
kids get and she wasn't responding to
the maintenance medication for asthma
and the doctors had pulled pastor dollar
aside and said look she's not gonna make
it she's one of these kids is just is
not gonna make him so steal yourself
prepare because she's a child that's not
gonna make it so I was introduced to him
at night listen you know he give her
like five or six different medications
they tried for months it doesn't work
and they try different medications
doesn't work well maintenance medication
for asthma works to prevent asthma
attacks and now it doesn't cure it but
it will prevent asthma attacks so the
reason I serve surmised that she wasn't
responding to these drugs she wasn't
absorbing them
she just wasn't absorbing on me and so I
put on a gluten-free diet so her
intestines would recover because when
you're gluten intolerant you're testing
this lose the ability to absorb things
so I put on a gluten-free diet gave her
the 90 essential nutrients appropriate
for her body weight for 11 year old kid
who's very skinny because she's
obviously not absorbing nutrients and so
forth and praise gotten too weak she was
cured a pastor dollar unsolicited gave
me a large sum of money a check
I said why I didn't ask for anything
pasties no no this is not for you for
you this is for you to do the study to
find out what causes diseases were said
to be genetic in the black community or
not I don't know how to prevent them I
want to know how to cure them so I spent
the money as he wished and came up with
this book and he bought the first
hundred thousand copies and we sell
about a million it easier every black
child in the world needs to read this
book because it goes into what causes
how to prevent and reverse sickle-cell
anemia
asthma obesity type 2 diabetes
alzheimers disease cardiovascular
disease high blood pressure none of
those things are in fact genetic they're
all simple nutritional deficiency
diseases easily prevented and easily
reversed it's all in the book black gene
lies there's pastor dollar and now this
11 year old girl who's now 30 who
[Applause]
okay this was a study I did in the
nineteen nineteen sixties when I came
back from Africa everyday just about
we're in the newspapers in central part
of the United States including Missouri
and Illinois and Indiana because of all
the work where we're doing all these
authors were finding all these diseases
and of course the senator wanted to let
people know we were spending their money
well and so they're sending out news
releases and Monsanto the chemical
company had a main office in st. Louis
and they donated a big hydroponic UNICEF
building that held these trays and racks
and watering systems and fertilizing
systems and you could grow soybeans you
could grow corn you could grow barley
grass or wheat whatever you wanted to
grow in there tomatoes and they opted to
set it up for barley grass so be almost
like giving a pasture to an animal in a
cage in the zoo
and Marlin Perkins said to me okay
Wallach we need to find out if we're
gonna be wasting a lot of time here or
the animals gonna eat it first of all
secondly is it gonna be a benefit to
Mars it's just something to play with
and roll around on given diary as more
things to clean up so find out for me so
make a long story short there is a pair
of mallard ducks simple barnyard ducks
in one of the zoo ponds and every spring
it happened to be spring they'd lay four
legs and they were being the eggs were
being fed to the various animals of it
eat eggs and so I said don't give the
four legs to the animals anymore but I
want you to do is start putting in the
refrigerator when you get 125 of them
let me know well three months later we
had a hundred and twenty-five of these
fertile eggs and refrigerators just like
human frozen embryos kind of thing right
and I set up four groups group number
one got chopped up head iceberg lettuce
for six weeks group number two got only
the chopped up hydroponically grown
barley grass from this new hydroponics
unit group number three the one that has
the ruler on it
got the ralston purina scientifically
constructed duck pellets for raising
baby ducks you know the one with the you
notice it the one with the ruler on it
is like three times as big there's the
other two groups and then the
hydroponically grown barley grass and
duck bells together group number four I
called it the baby Huey group
because they were five times bigger than
the number one number two groups say
mother father the mother and father
eating the same food for the entire two
or three months whatever it was to get
the hundred twenty-five eggs and the
only genetic difference between them was
some are boys and some were girls
otherwise genes are exactly the same
because the same other father same food
they got for the period of time where
they're laying those fertile eggs and
the only one that got the the nutrients
in such a level that it allowed them to
get the genetic potential for health and
longevity and fending off disease and
size and fitness and so forth wasn't one
that got both the hydropower your own
barley grass and duck pellets have this
experiment was written up in scientific
journals it's a big portion of a book
called rare earths urban cures and also
of course it became the first scientific
study done on the science of epigenetics
is in the mid 60s in 1967 I believe and
I'm considered one of the three fathers
of the science of epigenetics as a
result of that one little experiment
have a pressure every time went too fast
there apologize hybrid pleasure and
blacks not genetic okay say simple
nutritional deficiency the death of the
genetic theory disease transmission
remember James Watson he was one along
with Francis Crick proposed the the
double helix structure of DNA and he was
asked in March of 2013 to give a
progress report where are we had it been
60 years since they had proposed in 1953
the structure of DNA was a double helix
and over those six years there had not
been one disease cured with the genetic
engineering there been not one disease
prevented with genetic engineering what
was going on what were we going wrong
what's our status of genetics he gets up
in front of illustrious group in in San
Diego California
I was at the University of California
San Diego in the Salk Institute was
there to be the host and there were
three hundred and bited people I was not
one of them
and 150 of them half of them were Nobel
Prize winners from all over the world
they one of the best minds in the world
for this presentation the other 150 were
heads of departments of genetics and
biochemistry and chemistry at medical
schools all over North America Canada
United States in Mexico he got in from
this illustrious group kind of like I'm
standing in front of you now and I'm
gonna quote him now he said you can
sequence the genes of a hundred and
fifty thousand people that have what we
believe are genetically transmitted
disease such as sickle cell anemia type
2 diabetes things like cancer you're not
going to cure a single person now I said
a few more things that I'm going to
quote him again he said because all the
experiments we've done over the last 60
years in genetics have been irrelevant
I guarantee at that moment every heart
in that room started palpitating
eyebrows went up people stopped
breathing
and then he spoke for a little bit more
and then he said because nothing we have
thought to be Jacob transmitted is it's
all biochemistry aka
nutritional deficiencies and then they
fired him they fired him the National
Institutes of Health you may remember
that they fired him
now the first 90 days of pregnancy the
first trimester is when the baby's going
down the assembly line if mother's
missing something it's kind of like
going down the assembly line to Detroit
and the guy who has to put in the fuel
pump has the other bathroom he doesn't
stop the line he doesn't have somebody
come in fill in maybe 40 cars go by oh
by the time he gets back there's 40 cars
without a fuel pump same thing is true
with the mother with that babies the
babies farming she has to have
everything perfect all 60 minerals all
16 vitamins 12 amino acids free fatty
acids an optimum house to manufacture
that baby properly is God saw fit to
make us okay after that 90 days it's all
growth of course you can see how a human
embryo as is developing requires stuff
another way of looking at this is you
can take a blueprint of your dream home
by your dream lot on a lake or the
mountains and you throw that blueprint
on to the lot and come back here later
is that house built no the deer ate the
blueprint in the weeds or chest-high
there's no house because you needed you
needed skilled craftsmen concrete layers
carpenters roofers you need roofing
shingles you knew would you need a
drywall you need a brick and it all this
stuff same way with your genes they are
nothing but a blueprint doctors yet
still believe that genes are autonomous
they're gonna do what they're gonna do
regardless of how you eat what you do
it's not genetics anymore it's all
epigenetics okay what our ob/gyn is
doing wrong they should be held
accountable for all this that the fact
that our children I could live as long
as us they'll be the first generation in
America that our children who do not
live as long as us that's because when
the woman first comes whether she's an
18 year old when she's going there
because she has PMS she hasn't started
her period and she's concerned about
that sort of stuff are she going through
menopause or whatever yeah but those are
the shell bearing years the OBGYN nor
his nurse either give them a CD a DVD or
a pamphlet or a booklet that says you
must take all 90 essential nutrients to
prevent birth defects what I want you to
do is
somebody in your family or somebody you
know or someone in your church family or
somebody in your workplace either they
are young kids are dating seriously are
they're getting engaged or they're
getting married don't give them money
don't give them gift certificates do not
give them towels for their initials
monogrammed on it don't give them a set
of linens to start their household you
give them the 90 essential nutrients so
you won't be a grandparent babysitting a
special-needs child a disease called MS
multiple sclerosis historically has been
a disease of thirty five to fifty year
old people when it's diagnosed depending
on the number of lesions in the brain
how severe they are you might live
another 25 years gradually getting worse
worse worse and doctors trying to manage
the symptoms but today babies are being
born with MS multiple sclerosis and they
die within the first two years why
because of free radicals fried foods
processed meats you know things like
deli slices Salmons meats sausage ham
bacon Bologna salami pastrami pepperoni
jerky corned beef spam things like oils
microwave popcorn theater popcorn olive
oil coconut oil margins mayonnaise Hill
dressing cooking oils these turned into
trans fats which then causes
inflammatory damage of the white matter
of the brain is where you get MS
circulating around the mother's blood
goes into the baby's placenta it goes
into the baby and causes the problem in
babies we didn't have that stuff when I
was a kid because we didn't have those
types of foods tear rolls get strokes
now they get a blood clot in the brain
get a stroke and die
that never happened when I was a kid
strokes are caused by omega-3 essential
fatty acid deficiency it has nothing to
cholesterol in saturated fat lupus is a
very simple nutritional deficiencies
it's not autoimmune I don't care if
you've had it for 30 years it's
reversible you get on a gluten-free diet
so you can absorb the nutrients you get
on all 90 essential nutrients a little
bit of what we call the secret sauce so
your body can rebuild itself and lo and
behold God works his magic
Down syndrome you've all heard of Down
syndrome Down syndrome is caused by
deficiency have a single mineral in the
first division after the sperm
fertilizes the egg you're one celled
human being that minerals there an
optimal amounts the baby won't get down
syndrome but if there's not optimum
ounces at one mineral there's a high
probability that will be a Down syndrome
baby will up until about 25-30 years ago
the word was amongst the OB ions and
middle-aged women that middle-aged women
over age 35 were more apt to have a Down
syndrome baby how many heard that you
know were 35 you're more likely to have
a Down syndrome baby that was the way
things are going well today women in
their 20s and teens who get pregnant are
the ones more likely to have a Down
syndrome baby now Down syndrome is
reversible in the first two and a half
months of pregnancy either an
amniocentesis tests are an ultrasound
you can see the baby has Down syndrome
and it's reversible at that point I've
done it many many times my most famous
one was Lauren Knievel Evel Knievel's
niece in law and it's it's one of those
God things I call you give the body what
it needs even as an embryo it will
repair itself
sheral paul's you've all seen that in
various degrees it's a disease in which
the cerebellum the small part of the
brain in the back controls the fine
motor movement as it's under develop
because mama didn't have everything she
needed a little mouse for the proper
time when that part of the brain was
developing and the degree and the level
level of severity of zero palsy is
directly related to how long the
mother's deficiency was how severe the
deficiency was and so forth
this girl cost you five five million
dollars a year to take care of her
instead of her cerebellum when she was a
six pound baby severed her cerebellum
being the size of a small tangerine is
the size of a grape okay and so she's
totally disabled but she can hit
perfectly normal babies because this
isn't genetic she could marry a
perfectly normal young man she can marry
a boy with cerebral palsy and they can
use artificial insemination or whatever
you want to do how I get
pregnant they can have a perfectly
normal baby as long as she is taking the
90 essential nutrients because this is
not genetic of course the cerebellum is
that piece it looks like a a great
participant slides through in the lower
right hand corner of the brain the
smaller it is more catastrophic the
cerebellum disease truble palsy is
another one of my lawsuits against the
FDA was spina bifida women who know
about spina bifida heard of it you know
that folic acid the prenatal bottom
that's one of the things that I forced
the FDA to do to there was three of us
actually that sued the FDA to get folic
acid in prenatal vitamins prevent this
it's a terrible disease totally
unnecessary cripples children when it's
this advanced can occur anywhere along
the spinal cord but 80% of the time it's
in the lumbar area
Sammy's twins is a nutritional
deficiency the embryo why did they wait
so long to separate these kids s cause
they only room one liver in between them
triplets but there's only three sets of
legs the two small sets of legs there's
no torso no head no arms and took a
series of surgeries to separate them off
safely a totally preventable congenital
deafness for the babies born deaf has
nothing to do netic sit says simple
deficiency have a single mineral we've
known that since 1964 but doctors
continue to form institutions to raise
money to find the gene and what I would
do is say you know doctor I would love
to donate money to this fund to find the
gene for deafness but what I want to do
before I donate money I want to see a
copy of your taxes from last year
because I want to see how that money was
distributed that's when they'll say I'm
sorry I can't let you see that wait a
minute you're a publicly you know you're
a public institution I want to see your
tax return well you can't see that
that's because 99% of the money was
donated wound up in his pocket his fees
cleft palate totally preventable
terrible thing to inflict on a kid
because Mama's not getting the 90s sense
of nutrients on your left is a typical
belly button hernia the size of a walnut
easily repaired with the surgery the two
one in the middle of one of the right
hand size would be called gastroschisis
for the stomach and the liver and the
spleen oil intestines are hanging out
these two babies died during the birth
process they should have been delivered
by caesarian section they were perfect
in everybody there was nothing wrong
these baby I wasn't that they had
bellybutton hernias without skin over
them
everything came out during the forceful
contractions during birth and they died
of a stroke where was the doctor who's
supposed to be monitoring them oh he was
in the bathroom giving himself I'd be
drugs now how many of ever heard of
thalidomide till you're old enough
remember thalidomide for 10,000 babies
born in America examples are in the
middle and on your left where the babies
were born without arms and legs are
severely deformed arms and legs
this is because the mothers were given a
drug during pregnancy for morning
sickness called thalidomide now they had
never tested that drug on pregnant
laboratory animal to see if it impacted
the embryo 10,000 American families
suffer from this the pharmaceutical
company that actually made the drug paid
a couple of million dollars to the
government and fines and then the
families had to suffer by themselves
again had been one of the occasions when
I would have been found guilty of
temporary insanity right now you're
hearing about the Zika virus some of you
heard the Zika virus
okay these are two babies with
microcephaly the girl on your right is
10 years old her younger sister here is
only 2 years old
typical faces typical what they look
like as her head is very
there's 4700 4700 babies born in Brazil
between June and October of 2015
four thousand seven are babies with this
defect now people are blaming this on
the Zika virus although the same Zika
virus occurs in all or just about all of
South America and Mexico and the Bahamas
but nobody else has seen the same birth
defects so I suspect there's something
else going on there okay there's
something else going on there are they
giving these women a new drug for
morning sickness are these women
celebrating because it's some holiday
there and they're all out drinking that
part of the pregnancy I don't know
there's something else going on there
because the Zika virus alone is not
going to cause this this gal and you're
right is ten years old before the Zika
virus okay have you even read some of
the Greek mythology you heard of the
Cyclops terrible warrior with one eye in
the middle of his forehead he his
greatest joy was to hold you and meet
your head you know kind of stuff
here's a kitten with cycloptic eye
here's a sheep my cycloptic eye here's a
shark with cycloptic eye so when you
have two vertebrates from different
families and captain is a carnivore lamb
is a herbivore out there eating grass
and the shark of course as a fish like
critter and they all have the cycloptic
eye so that tells you that it's not
genetic in any way shape or form it's a
simple nutritional deficiency here's a
six-month-old human baby with Cyclops
because mom wasn't getting those
nutrients during pregnancy some of these
kids are strong enough that they will
grow up no in the third world culture is
where they have villages and they're
still hunter-gatherers when you have a
baby born like this they're usually
suffocated or drowned because it would
be a huge burden because they're barely
making enough living hunting herbs and
food and catching rabbits to survive
with 1012 families in there let alone
have four or five babies with birth
defects so you know you don't see them
in third world cultures because they're
dispatched if you will when they're born
in animals farm animals and pet animals
reports cycloptic
babies one on 16,000 each year because
we supplement them so it's a fairly rare
defect in humans is one in 250 they
don't see many of them because almost
all of them are miscarried almost all
miscarriages are cycloptic babies
because they have so many things going
wrong on the inside of them they don't
make it the Yerkes Institute Emory
University in Atlanta Georgia in 1977 I
found the first non-human case of [__]
Barossa did biopsies on the other 24
baby monkeys and that facility did not
have any relationship genetically to
that monkey and they all had severe
doses I knew Amelia was a it was a
environmental thing tracked it down did
the chemistry's figured it out published
got it ready for publication took it to
Emory University the powers would be
rating Memorial Hospital and the new
yorkese primate Center and they fired me
should have been a Nobel Prize but they
fired me well just before they fired me
on the letterhead of experts around the
world they all agreed that my tissues
from this one monkey which I didn't tell
him was a monkey I just said what do you
think this is a classic examples to see
red roses and so when originally turned
it in Emory University made a news
release hey we're wonderful in they beat
their chests we found the first
non-human case this is where both says
we're gonna have laboratory animals they
can study it and everybody's excited and
then when I did the rest of my research
and found out that it wasn't genetic
that's when they fired me that was 1978
in 2005 the scientific journal from the
US Department of Health and Human
Services of the
okay if they came out with this the
International amateur animal research
journal and the federal government had
defunded in June of 2005 primate
research had defunded it because too
expensive ten thousand dollars a day per
monkey whereas for Mouse is ten cents a
day and so they said you have to use
mice if you want to use monkeys go to
Warren Buffett or Bill Gates Foundation
get the money there we're not going to
give it to you this particular issue
they spent the entire issue looking at
primate research projects that benefited
human health over the years so they took
the 20th century as the example the 20th
century and they picked the top 10
research sections
in primates top 10 which showed benefit
to the humans
number 2 out of the top 10 was my
project on the city versus monkeys back
in 1977 this is 2005 the last sentence
in the part on [__] burrows has said in
brackets Emory University refused to
release the name of the young
pathologist who made the discovery now
why did they put that in there because
they wanted people to know they weren't
that stupid because Emory University had
made a news release it went out of
everywhere every newspaper in the world
had that story when it first came out
every newspaper in the world had this
story well they told these guys if you
put wall ixnay min there we're gonna
fire you and so they kind of put their
toes on the free-throw line as far as
they could go and hope somebody else
would follow up on it of course nobody
did but the stories in the book
epigenetics these are the kids you see
with severe paralysis
now 1989 I went to Keyshawn promised
China where did those 1700 autopsies on
kids under the age of 10
the data Keshawn disease which was
cardiomyopathy heart disease that sudden
heart attack death there occurs because
of its efficiency of a single mineral
and that deficiency that same mineral is
what causes cirrhosis the deficiency for
that same mineral is what causes most
your district that's not unusual there's
a hundred and forty seven different
diseases that are caused by a calcium
deficiency okay
so I went there to do two thousand
autopsies on these kids and because of
delays and and political and national
things at hoops I had to jump and so
forth it cost me a week and so I was
only able to do one thousand seven
hundred instead of two thousand but I
was hoping to find fifteen twenty thirty
babies that had cirrhosis to show that
there was a relationship
well I failed it that I didn't find
twenty kids with cirrhosis I found five
hundred ninety five fully 35 percent I
found 100 percent of those kids that
died also had muster dystrophy and 200
of them
had SIDS sudden infant death syndrome
was the theory for SIDS ladies well the
baby suffocated cause he's sleeping on
his belly instead of sleeping I was back
no no another group of doctor said no no
they were sleeping on their back and
shouldn't sleep another belly but none
of them looked they didn't do the
special stains to see the damage in the
heart which I did turned out to be SIDS
the same deficiency causes cirrhosis the
same deficiency that causes muster
dystrophy oh yeah I found 100 percent of
those 1,700 hit muster dystrophy also 15
years later after dealing with thousands
of Amish kids because the Amish children
have 10 15 20 times more mustard history
and sincere doses than not Amish
families because their lifestyle is very
similar to the lifestyle these people in
Keshawn promised china so make a long
story short I picked a hundred of the
best records over 15 years where their
doctors said the baby was cured a
mustard his fame gave him to Jerry Lewis
five six six years ago now and he was
excited I said Jerry your these are
Jerry's kids you deserve the right to
make the announcements we have found the
cause friends and cure of mustard
history he took it to the muster
dystrophy association and they fired him
that's why he hasn't done the telethon
for the last five years they should have
their nonprofit standing taken away from
them and all the people were on the
board at that time should be put in jail
because every kid is born now with
mustard history our dies from it is on
their head may God forgive them
congestive heart failure deficients have
a single vitamin Carter map the heart
disease which we just discussed which is
Keshawn disease deficiency of a single
mineral coronary artery disease is
caused by inflammation microwave popcorn
fried foods processed meat salad
dressings these kinds of things coronary
thrombosis caused by deficiency but
mega-tree is essential fatty acids
cholesterol is not part of the whole
deal there is the evil one microwave
popcorn there's one of the reasons why
your children will not live as long as
your you I'll show you the the
front-page news story in a moment where
this was in there
fifty thousand heart attacks a year in
kids and twenty thousand of them die
from microwave popcorn remember I told
you earlier that cholesterol and
saturated fat doesn't cause coronary
artery disease it's inflammation from
eating trans fats and hero cycling means
the demonization of cholesterol and
saturated fat saying that they were the
cause of blocked arteries and heart
attacks and so forth was to sell a new
product at Procter & Gamble wanted to
sell in 1952 called Crisco so Procter &
Gamble through the efforts of a medical
doctor who is a professor of medicine
the university Minnesota he was also on
the board of Procter & Gamble he was
also aboard American Heart Association
and he brokered the deal were were
Procter & Gamble gave the American Heart
Association back in 1952 1.7 million
dollars to endorse Crisco is a healthier
way to eat and lard cream and butter
there was no science to show that but
they took the 1.7 million dollars in
endorsed Crisco oh I have to tell you
Chris Joe started out in 1901 the German
Navy went to a German chemist by the
name of Wilhelm Norman said look we need
a smokeless synthetic diesel submarine
lubricant
and four years later in 1904 he came up
with what we now call Crisco after this
first world war they didn't need any
more so they sold the patent to a soap
manufacturing company in England which
owned it until after the Second World
War and they couldn't sell very much
soap because everybody's making their
own soap and then after the Second World
War Procter & Gamble bought it through
through again the efforts of Ancel keys
that medical doctor and they gave the
American Heart Association 1.7 million
dollars to demonize cholesterol
saturated lard creme eggs and butter so
they could sell Crisco now I look for 35
years to find the paper there was a
pivotal paper showing the saturated fat
and Crisco caused heart disease and
artery disease couldn't find it and then
about three years ago now a billionaire
who I'm helping with his health I was up
in Canada he shipped me a copy that Wall
Street Journal was a to full page
article on the story of how Procter &
Gamble paid the American Heart
Association 1.7 million dollars to
demonize cluster on central fat so they
could sell Crisco
and they weren't selling much even
though the American Heart Association
endorsed Crisco they couldn't sell much
still because it wasn't very romantic or
sexy
so Keyes decided to come up with a a
program that made it more sexy to eat
Crisco and he came up with the
Mediterranean diet the Mediterranean was
never a study it was always just a sales
campaign to sell Crisco get over it
there's quiche on China and of course in
September see me in January in January
of 2015
another one of our lawsuits with the FDA
we got selenium and being approved to
put into infant formulas sometime the
next couple of days I want you to go buy
a pharmacy or go buy a grocery store and
look at infant formula cat the analyses
label on the infant farm of the
ingredients label there's gonna be three
to five minerals in there we need 60
where's the baby gonna get the other 57
to 55 unless you supplement them you're
gonna be burying them so it comes down
to well we got selenium to be able to be
put in there now so in the next couple
of months they should be adding the
selenium remember SIDS is caused by a
deficiency of this mineral most risky is
caused by a deficiency in this mineral
quite a myopic a heart disease is caused
by divisions in this mineral and also
assistir it roses these are the Chinese
kids
Keshawn promises that red promised up in
the upper right hand corner kind of like
New England and China mainland China red
current professor medicine University of
Colorado normal plasma cholesterol an 8
year old man he's 25 eggs a day came out
March of 1991 in the New England Journal
of Medicine a publication from Harvard
Medical School he's examining this guy
showing newly graduated doctors how to
examine a senior and he says wait a
minute you're all your blood tests Sarah
says you're in your 50s you look like
you're 50 and then your birth date says
you're a TA is this you he said yes me
says everybody says that what do you
attribute your youthful looks to and in
your health which we can document
according to the blood work he says well
he stood up and he threw his shoulders
back and puffed his chest I said I ate
25 eggs a day
of course that mortified the doctor
that's not what he wanted these students
to hear
and he says okay sir I can see him
Fanning himself that wasn't in the
report but I can see him Fanning himself
with the clipboard very nervous he said
okay why does she 25 eggs a day and he
said that's because it made me more
studly don't you think about this
testosterone estrogen progesterone
adrenal hormones are four steroid
hormones they're 95% by weight
cholesterol so you go on a cholesterol
stricted I take statin drugs lower your
cholesterol
there ain't nobody home anymore
now the pharmacy industry the
pharmaceutical industry loved that they
came out with Viagra and Cialis and now
they got women's viagra they're having
the time of their lives and of course
they're pumping out statin drugs as much
as they can to get you in that situation
they're burning the candle they're
burning your candle at both ends so to
speak these three time a gazebo forgives
you the whole story of cholesterol
there's a picture in 1961 of Ancel keys
the guy who brokered the deal between
Procter and Gamble in the American Heart
Association or the 1.7 million dollars
he was considered the savior of the
American cardiovascular system because
he pointed out for the first time the
cholesterol was a demon and he looks
like a Nazi doesn't he in the Time
magazine cover 1984 again demonizing
cholesterol was a paid ad then 2014
cover article Time magazine eat butter
why scientists labeled saturated fat the
enemy and why they were wrong was a 5
page story on Ancel keys and how he
brokered the deal for 1.7 million
dollars to get the American Heart
Association to endorse Crisco without
one scientific article on it the culture
on earth that has the fewest
cardiovascular events they have no heart
attacks no strokes or the Inuit Eskimos
above the Antarctic Circle they actually
live on nothing but whale meat and whale
blubber Walters mean walrus blubber seal
meat and seal blubber bear mean bear fat
they don't eat fruit they don't eat
vegetables they don't eat nuts it on any
grain their cholesterol is run 350 to
500 that's been reported at least 25
times a year for the last 1215 years if
doctors don't pay attention to this
they're the ones that came up with the
concept of sit around the fire and chew
the fat see they're all eating raw whale
fat right here
no the only time they're going to get a
heart attack or stroke is if they come
to New Jersey and eat like you Pam
you're dead salt is not bad in fact salt
has two very very very essential
nutrients sodium and chloride and
doctors and their ignorance have
demonized again sodium and chloride
they're both the essential nutrients and
any doctor who tells you you need to
restrict cell you got high blood
pressure you should immediately get up
walk out go home and on the internet
fire them immediately because they have
shortened your life by about 25 years to
get on a salt restricted diet 1982 salt
a new villain 2014 salt doesn't cause
high blood pressure I said that in 71 in
some of my publications science news
very famous very well-respected
scientific journal the lead article in
June of 2012 good cholesterol not
beneficial wait a minute my doctor says
is everything the subtitle was higher
HDL high density lipoprotein good
cholesterol high good cholesterol levels
don't reduce heart attacks you know why
congestive heart failure is caused by
deficiency of a single vitamin card
mouthy heart disease is a deficiency of
a single mineral coronary artery disease
is caused by inflammation eating fried
foods processed meats oils gluten
microwave popcorn Lakan stuff and then
thrombotic stroke and coronary
thrombosis we get a blood clot in the
coronary artery is caused by not close
from saturated fat but a deficiency
omega-3s are a racial pawn between
omega-3 sixes and nines this is what
kills your kids they come home from
school they're Dunkin their Oreo cookies
and some zero fat milk and or maybe even
rice milk or soy milk which is has no
relationship nutritionally in the milk
whatsoever we should be against the law
for them to call those things milk the
white icing in there is nothing but
margarine that hasn't been dyed yellow
is just nothing but trans fats and
heterocyclic amines and acrylamide cause
inflammation plug the arteries and cause
many many other diseases and of course
margin is the worst type of fat for well
my doctor says I have to use margin set
of butter
remember that's why they live to be 56
okay now this is where we got that
statistic which said that that microwave
popcorn and theater popcorn causes
50,000 heart attacks and kids every year
in America and 20,000 deaths in kids you
know we sent them a note saying look
we're gonna sue you for the tenth time
now and this is on trans fats it's been
long enough you need to get this stuff
out of the food that was in January of
2015 when we got that nod from the FDA
that we could demand that legally that
they put two slain him into baby
formulas okay we're going on to the 10th
lawsuit now the FDA six months later in
June of 2015 said the FDA is now to trim
trans fats out of food well that's not
good enough
they should have done it immediately you
have 30 days to get trans fat out of
your product or we're taking your
product off the market but they're gonna
give them a grace period of six months
or year whatever it is and so I feel
that that's okay because there's no
statute of limitations on murder is
there now raise your hand if you've
heard that exercise is good for you you
don't raise your emember this is a house
of God
whether you believe it or not have you
heard that exercise good for you okay
that's better that's better
okay but turns out if you take all
professional athletes from all sports
and combine the data the average
lifespan is 62 except for a football
players is 51 professional footballer is
that's according to insurance actuaries
and there's never been a professional
athlete ever live to be 100
now the top professional athletes they
make five six eight ten million dollars
a game the top athletes get pampers they
get massages ten times a day they get
the best food to get the best personal
trainers I mean I mean it'd be like you
ladies who your whole life is around
knitting you just love it in it I mean
grant some grandma that's it their whole
life they want to knit for all their
grandkids and great-grandkids and then
you never see him without their knitting
news man they're just going at it right
what have you got paid five million
dollars every Saturday when you're
knitting for knitting would that be cool
I mean what a great profession and yet
there's never been a professional
athlete ever lived to be a hundred some
of those you know of Jim Fixx
top runner in fact he was a professor of
economics and one of the Ivy League
colleges up here I don't remember which
one
he died a fifty-two of cardiomyopathy
heart attack a deficient at one minute
while he was running his protege Brian
Maxwell from Canada had 12 gold medals
in long-distance running
he invented the power bar nestles gave
him 300 million dollars for the rights
of power bar and then three months later
he died while he was running at age 51
of a cardiomyopathy a heart attack he's
not a fitness guru anymore he's just goo
Reggie Lewis 28 years old captain of the
Boston Celtics collapsed during a
playoff game of the Charlotte Hornets
way back then 1994 I believe it was and
he survived and and the top cardiologist
in America is a cardiologist for the
astronauts and NASA he was the head of
the department of cardiology at Harvard
Medical School
gave him a minimum exercise regimen he
could just stand at the free-throw line
and throw free throws and he put him on
like six different drugs for his card
him apathy heart disease and two weeks
later he died from the second Carter map
the heart attack because nobody gave him
two cents worth of selenium here's that
cardiologist dr. W Thomas ness I ran the
Boston Marathon 20 times he was
considered the world's top cardiologist
and he dies in the cardiomyopathy heart
disease a year and a half after Reggie
did at age 48 his 16 year old kid on the
left Wes Leonard Fennville Michigan a
semi finals playoff sudden-death when he
got the points his four teammates on the
court are lifting him up in front of
10,000 cheering local fans and he dies
in their arms of a cardiomyopathy a
heart attack the County Examiner medical
examiner who did the autopsy on him says
we don't know why he died of this heart
attack it could have been the stresses
of sports
now that guy should go to jail because
every time a kid dies from this is
because he didn't say it was caused by
deficiency of selenium he's he go to
jail for that the girl on your right
Rennell the Pierce was a freshman at
Florida State University she dropped
dead a ruptured aneurysm while in the
middle of a game
19 years old and the doctor said she had
a genetic disease called Kawasaki's
disease babies are born with aneurysms
and they died within a couple of months
of a ruptured aneurysm and this has
taught to be a genetic disease because
babies are born with this this goes back
to the days of what Darwin write in the
1800s it's actually a nutritional
deficiency of a single mineral a single
mental deficiency results in a breakdown
of the elastic fibers in your blood
vessel you can get spider veins varicose
veins hemorrhoids and
aneurisms from a deficiency that mineral
and it wasn't a genetic disease in a
girl she just had a deficiency because
she's drinking one of the other sports
drinks Gatorade has two nutrients not
that one Powerade has six nutrients not
that one these are kids top ten
obituaries in the first couple of months
of this year in the first couple months
of last year these are all kids that
died under the age of 15 from
cardiomyopathy and heart attacks right
here in America girls cheerleaders
softball players peewee leagues this is
just ten of them 20,000 of these kids
die every year in America McCarty
myopathy heart attack or ruptured
aneurysms because nobody's told their
parents or grandparents that they need
the 90 essential nutrients somebody
needs to go to jail a hockey player is
16 years old died Karmapa the heart
disease the doctors up in Canada said
they still don't know the cause of his
death here's some of your favorite
professional athletes
I love this one I mean he is one
mean-looking dude look at that look at
his six-pack look at the biceps I mean
his biceps were bigger than
schwarzenegger x' and he died of a
deficiency of a single mineral pam he
was dead
this one this fella here was a
cardiologist and also a professional
soccer player in brazil and he died
during a soccer game at age 57 so what's
going on here
athletes with your professional athlete
are not sweat no drink a lot of water to
rehydrate which is not a bad thing but
sweat is not water sweat is a soup that
contains all the nutrients floating
around your blood let's say you're not
supplementing you have 6575 nutrients
floating around in there and you're just
drinking water you'll get a breakdown in
your tendons and ligaments you'll have
muscle tears your discs will blow out
you'll collapse during a game and die
you take the 90 essential nutrients now
that'll ever happen because you'll be
replacing what you sweat out so we came
up with rebound
remember Gatorade has two nutrients
power he has six our rebound has 100
including the selenium and the mineral
is missing when you get ruptured
aneurysms okay now this is Theo Ratliff
from Atlanta Georgia he was playing with
the Hawks had you know 28 years old had
bone to bone or I suppose knees that
Cartledge popped off his right hip he
broke his wrist catching a pass from a
teammate during a regulation game that
the doctors of the Lana Hawks had looked
this guy's too fragile play ball he took
his contract away from him and young
introduced me to him we rebuilt him in
90 days he got his position back he
played for 14 more years he made a
hundred and forty million dollars using
our rebound because we're replacing
everything that he was sweating out and
his wife Christina loves me
now we're gonna change subjects here a
little bit but very very very important
subject this is in the news all right
now this is one of the fastest drawing
problems in the United States because
there's more and more young kids who are
gay or lesbian or bisexual transgender
asexual and this is not a choice this is
a congenital event I'll call it's a
congenital event mom is missing
something at the time when the preoptic
epithalamus of brain is farming there's
two things that happen when the sperm
fertilizes the egg instantly you're
either gonna be an xx female or XY male
genetically but the preoptic
hypothalamus their brain goes off in a
different direction it might take you
know seven weeks the third to seventh
week of pregnancy which is three to
seven weeks after you were determined
structurally to be a boy or a girl
physiologically to be a boy or girl but
who you received signals from who you
give signals to is determined by that
part of the brain which develops three
to seven weeks later this is not a
choice this is a this is a congenital
event I don't want to use the word birth
defect but it's a congenital event the
same principle as a birth defect when
you look at the holy books the Old
Testament the New Testament the Quran
you look at the holy books for the
Hindus and the holy books for the Shin
twos in Japan all these holy books talk
about two categories of disease one is
infectious diseases epidemics plagues
leprosy and they always talk about
homosexuality all of them talk about
homosexuality none of them talk about
Down syndrome now to talk about cleft
palate none of them talk about cerebal
palsey which are very easy thing you
don't even know what it is but you can
describe it back in those days three
thousand five thousand years ago
generals and rich wealthy merchants and
kings and Pharaohs used to collect
babies with birth defects they would
send their soldiers out to give the
villagers some money to get the baby
with a birth defect they called them
monsters in those days like the kids
that are just horribly deformed
okay and they would drown them or
suffocate them and they put them in
bottles of alcohol some of these
collections have thirty thousand fifty
thousand infants in them and over the
years the families gave them to the
medical museums of Europe in the United
States in the book epigenetics I give
you the names of the museums and the
names of the collections that are in
there so you can go look at them if you
want so we know those birth defects
happened back then those physical birth
defects happened back then but the holy
books only talked about homosexuality
and infectious diseases and this is
what's going on at this time okay June
2014 cover story on transgenders now
this is a white-tailed deer from upstate
New York anybody here ever go hunting
not many okay a few over here
all right well white-tailed deer are
very interesting they were common deer
cross North America and this was an
upstate New York during hunting season
this fella sees what's a record set of
antlers I mean he knows this is boone
and crockett this is a record set of
antlers and it's what open sights he
shoots the deer goes up to dress it to
cut it open and take all the guts out
you realize this is a girl this female
deers don't have antlers this is the
equivalent of a bearded lady in a circus
and in that same area where those
transgender deer are they have the
highest rate of transgender humans in
America because the food that they're
eating from that same soil if there is
deficient in these nutrients there's
1,500 species of vertebrates including
African animals free-ranging African
animals zoo animals from all over the
world 1,500 domestic animals pet animals
that have been documented to have
transgender behavior gay and lesbian
behavior you know Sonny cher Bono they
had chastity became chaste and then
there was Angelina Jolie and Brad Pitt
had Shiloh who became John and those are
common things right now there's seven
hundred thousand registered transgender
in America there's fifty thousand
transgenders serving with honor and our
military
now this fellow here on your left dr.
Richard Raskin was a very famous eye
surgeon who invented the laser surgery
to tack down torn retinas he didn't have
to cut the eyeball open he also at the
top-ranked tennis player amateur tennis
player in the world
his last child reached 18 years of age
is 35 years ago this is 35 years ago the
last child reached 18 years of age he
went to Denver and became renee Richards
35 years before Bruce Jenner became
Caitlyn but the thing that made this a
big story that went on for couple of
years was that renee Richards wanted to
keep the top ranking in the tennis
amateur tennis thing as a girl when it
transferred from the boy to the girl and
in the end the Supreme Court awarded
renee Richards the title then of course
you know the story of Bruce Jenner you
need to read Vanity Fair if you haven't
read it there's 25 pages it's
essentially his biography and he knew
and he was a little kid when he's two or
three years old that he would rather be
a girl than a boy but he had all the
physical equipment of a boy and so he
worked real hard and and push-ups and
running and walking and chin-ups and all
this kind of stuff to be as strong as he
could and he'd run and run and run he
won all these medals and he lettered in
university and many sports because
structurally and physically he was a boy
but in his preoptic hypothalamus he was
a girl because mother didn't eat the
right things and didn't get the right
things during that part of the pregnancy
of course this pink pinwheel in the
middle of the brain there that's the
part that little Peninsula hanging down
the size your little finger is a pre
optic hypothalamus
they're supposed to be 450 cells in
there by actual count to be a
heterosexual there's no cells in there
and this happens many times no cells in
there guess what you're you're a asexual
person crazy aunt Ruthy who never would
get in a car alone with a boy she would
be the one to wash all your clothes and
babysit your kids are
everybody loves her she's the best cook
in the family she'd send out all your
Christmas cards fur and lick all the
stamps but don't get her near a boy and
then there's crazy Uncle Frank who never
would sit in a car with a girl all you
want to do is rotate your tires and work
on your carburetor mow your lawn thanks
Otis stuff trim your trees weed your
garden but he did not want to be around
girls those are asexual people they have
no cells in that part of the brain and
then you have say 200 cells in the brain
and 100 cells say chase boys 100 cells
chase girls you're bisexual let's say
those 200 cells they'll land on the side
that say chase girls and you're an XY
boys genetically and chase girls your
girl craze is good but if your girl xx
and it says chase girls your lesbian now
let's say all those 200 cells fall on
the side that says chase boys if you're
a girl you're an X X girl you chase boys
that your boy crazy that's a good thing
but if your boy your XY genetically and
this part of your brain says chase boys
you're gay then if you have your 450
cells you're straight you're
heterosexual so we're in command of this
after the fact it can't be reversed now
and there may be some time when we can
genetically engineer cells and put the
right cells in the right place and
change things but right now we don't
have technology but it's totally
preventable
okay this is that June 15th
Time magazine centerfold these kids are
all cousins the mothers are sisters from
the same grandmother one mother is the
mother of the two children that have the
pink outfits the second sister is the
mother of the child with the yellow
outfit
the third mother all three sisters is a
mother of the child with the blue outfit
all the boys are fishing in the farm
pond these four kids are picking flowers
and tripping through the meadow singing
little girly songs obviously by looking
at the one in the blue on your right
physically as a boy XY but in his brain
and his preoptic hypothalamus he's a
girl we already talked about obesity
being a deficiency of a single category
and nutrients experts say 70% of our
kids under the age of 12 are overweight
40% of our kids on the age of 12 are
obese
35 pounds of overweight and it has
nothing to do with eating too much or
lack of exercise this little girl here
Natalie Hayhurst from Terre Haute
Indiana has the same deficiencies but
she didn't gain any weight because her
mother was kind of a anti fat anti soda
freak had nothing in the house would
make you gain weight so she ate
lightbulbs she was on the news all the
time because she ate lipo there's no
calories in lightbulbs so she ate weird
things but she didn't gain any weight
cuz there's no calories in lightbulbs
malabsorption can be a cause of obesity
because even if you supplement with
those nutrients you can't absorb them
you're gonna gain weight cuz the symptom
of a deficiency in these nutrients is
the munchies now this is Newark New
Jersey in 1920 these girls were told
that exercise is going to help them lose
weight while they're having a lot of fun
and some sisterhood stuff there but
guess what they're gonna be disappointed
Loyola University School of Medicine
Chicago January 2009 they did a 10-year
study exercise will not make you lose
weight eight months later in August of
2009 cover article Time magazine the
myth about exercise it won't make you
lose weight okay and pastor you may know
this individual I haven't led better
from Charlotte North Carolina
I met him almost four years ago now he
weighed 423 pounds he's in the picture
on the left in the pink shirt and honor
program he lost 17 pounds in the first
week first time in his whole life he
never lost any weight
we added what we call ASAP it's a kind
of an accelerator that's an acronym for
as slim as possible as soon as possible
and he lost 60 pounds in the first 30
days two pounds a day went from 400
pounds and then in seven months he
dropped down to 165 and then the right
hand picture he is the one looking at
you over his right shoulder same guy
that weighed 400 pound 4 and 23 pounds
when I met him he has not gained a half
ounce back because he stayed in the 19th
century it's a simple nutritional
efficiency and it's not unusual to lose
a half a pound of 2 pounds a day and
some people need to lose more than 100
pounds I see people who are 400 600 800
pounds they'll lose 4 pounds a day they
never have to have any surgery because
they're getting all the nutrients and
the skin tightens up as they lose the
weight and they never have to have any
surgery for loose skin now this is a
horse barn an Amish horse and buggy
Amish horse farm in Adams County Indiana
just south of Fort Wayne Indiana and I
was there to see monster dystrophy kids
but they were late and so being a
veterinarian and a physician I went into
the barn to look around the animals and
this is called cribbing in animals
called munchies and people
and we choose rather than eat the
furniture we choose to eat something
that could cause us to gain weight
osteoporosis and arthritis is a simple
deficiency of vitamins and minerals has
nothing with age or genetics it is
repairable you can actually give your
body the raw materials to support and
promote maintenance the repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between the vertebra bone
makes a bona sell unless you've been run
over by a tank nobody ever needs to get
a joint replacement I'm gonna repeat
that unless you get run over by a tank
nobody ever has to get a joint
replacement so why would them what a
doctor once you get joint replacement
because he makes $2,500 every time he
does it
Cole is linked to bone brakes because
you're getting a lot of phosphorus in
Nichola which replaced the cocaine and
this phosphorus messes up the calcium
phosphate ratio and that's why you have
a lot of young athletes to get fractures
you get a lot of middle-aged people who
do a hard physical work at fractures
because you're drinking soft drinks
calcium deficiency causes kidney stones
every one of them there's no exception
you go to your algae's you have a kidney
so nice oh my god you got to get rid of
dairy out of your life anthalie if
you're on supplements account you got to
stop that we got to get all the calcium
out of your life here your blood calcium
is too high and you're getting kidney
stones no just the opposite you need to
take more calcium your blood calcium
will come down you won't get any more
kidney stones popular osteoporosis drugs
are pulled off the market
pazzo maxwell phosphate phosphorus too
much phosphorus that was a dumb idea on
their part another failed medical theory
and they wanted you to believe ladies
that women got osteoporosis when they
went through menopause because they
didn't have enough estrogen raise your
hand ladies have you ever heard that one
well you were duped on that one men get
osteoporosis more frequently and more
severely than women now that was a
failed medical theory because little
girls got osteoporosis when little girls
get osteoporosis they call it osteo
Malaysia and kids this is how she
approached isn't kids girl simulation
gave it a different name because a
different age group you take the 90
essential nutrients with some secret
sauce to rebuild the the not only the
rebar and the bone but also help you put
more minerals of your bones and I don't
care if you have osteopenia osteoporosis
osteoarthritis generalized bone MRIs
rheumatoid arthritis bone divan
arthritis kidney stones you have a
history of bone spurs calcium deposits
periodontal disease it's all nutritional
deficiencies particularly calcium and
vitamin d3 and and some of the like Oh
strontium is another one you need to
have to prevent fractures and so on and
so you need a program we have the 90
essential nutrients but what we call the
secret sauce or to talk about during the
QA this is Andy Young Zim living room in
1991 I was there because I had written
so many articles on how to prevent
sickle cell anemia and how to address it
better and make it better for people
more efficiently than drugs and so he
called me from from California to
Atlanta this is a living room and I
noticed he was limping I said with all
due respects mr. ambassador why are you
limping he said well I got bone to bone
or thright us and both knees I'm
scheduled in two weeks to have a double
knee replacement I said sir with all due
respects give me 90 days cancel your
surgery delay it give me 90 days I can
rebuild that for it without surgery is
I'm going to Emory University I'm going
to great Memorial Hospital the best
doctors in the world where they're the
ones that fired me over the Cystic
Fibrosis thing so I let him have an
earful of that and then he cancelled his
surgeries I'll give you 90 days 90 days
I rebuilt him and he introduced me to a
lot of people after that we still do a
lot of things together okay he
introduced me to Lisa Jones who was on
that women's basketball team America for
the Olympics that won all the gold
medals and she's training for the third
Olympics and she's 40 years old in this
picture and rebuilt her hamstring
rebuilt her Achilles tendon the surgeons
who put her back together said look
you're not gonna play at the same skill
level you might think of coaching rather
than playing she got her position back
she got her third gold medal and this is
a son stage in California I'm giving her
a certificate saying she's an ambassador
for women athletes for youngevity
company
well they allowed me to ask you one
question said delecia I've got to ask
you one question I'm allowed to ask you
one question this has been since I've
met you you know a couple of years ago
has been really I have to know the
answer this machine okay doc whatever
you want now we're in front of 3,000
people I said delecia I have to know why
does a woman who's six foot five were
eight inch heels
and she says well doc is simple which
makes you more sexy this is a Harvard
Medical School that was published in the
New England Journal of Medicine and
abstracted in newspapers these search
for arthritis is worthless they looked
at the records of 300 thousand people
who had knee replacement surgeries and
hip replacement surgery and they found
out that this knee replacement surgery
for arthritis is worthless because the
bone contingent deteriorate doesn't stop
the problem and so that's where Andy
young of course this came out after I
had talked with him okay I had talked to
him in 1991 and here at came as a sieve
master we're way ahead of yeah you're
right
okay so even heard of Medical School now
agrees with me give me 90 days before
you have any joints replace okay you
won't get the surgery same thing with
the back four years later they looked at
the same three hundred thousand records
but this time they looked at the back
and they looked at the the discs in
between the vertebrae and peripheral
neuropathies and sciatica and lower back
pain do not get surgery give me 90 days
first and doing God's thing guess what
you won't need the surgery thank you
type two diabetes now
the Pima Indians are worth five minutes
here or less three to five minutes the
Pima Indians there their range where
they live spreads from Arizona in the
southern southwestern part of United
States Arizona and you can look and you
can see that line which is the border of
United States and Mexico going
underneath the eye and then through the
middle of the pea under Pima that little
bit of yellow above the line there is
10% of the Pima Indian population is
above the line in Arizona and 90% of the
Pima Indians down in the yellow below
which makes them about a third of the
western part of the mainland of Mexico
okay they're all the same gene pool
they're the only Native Americans who
never mixed with anybody else every
other Native American tribe makes other
Native Americans they mixed with the
slaves when they were freed after
emancipation because they wanted the
skills in farming and industry and so
forth but the Pima Indians are the only
ones who didn't even mess around with
the Explorers okay they're perfect 170
million genes the ones are left here the
Mexican Pima Indians they're kind of
like the Amish they don't participate in
anything we think of as being first
world they're sort of subsistence
farmers and they're on the side of the
road here selling jars if they make out
of pottery pottery jars and things they
don't have vehicles no roads they go
everywhere on horseback or walk they use
horses to plow these horses pool wagons
they have no utilities no doctors I mean
they just sort of say to themselves okay
these are the Mexican communities that's
below the line they make up 90% of the
population of Pima Indians above the
line 10% of the Pima Indians in America
in Arizona they work in the RV assembly
factories in Arizona they're all obese
including the kids they all have a car a
van a pickup truck all use doctors now
let's have a look let's look at the
Mexican Mexican Pima Indians in diabetes
rate type 2 diabetes rate they have the
lowest rate of diabetes the entire world
6% or less let's look at the Pima
Indians above the border
in Arizona BAM 46% they have the highest
rate they have the highest rate of
diabetes of anywhere in the world same
genetics same genetics
accor this mystifies doctors but I'm
going to show you why in just a few
moments the cases of type 2 diabetes are
doubling every year now it's going in a
in a geometric proportions
three-year-old babies are now weighs 77
pounds away as much as 10 year olds more
blacks lose legs to diabetes and whites
that's not because it's a genetic thing
that's because the black community is
enslaved by the medical community
[Applause]
remember the story that Coretta Scott
King told me and these are the things
that dr. King was going against because
they say the outrageous things that
doctors do to the black population pale
the Tuskegee experiments when you read
that book epigenetic you will cry
cancers a self-inflicted disease it is
not genetic in any way shape or form all
the studies on chemotherapy cannot be
duplicated because none of it's true
the FDA relies on research done by the
pharmaceutical companies that makes it
they don't say we're gonna do an
experiment and see if we can come up
with the same results before you approve
it they just approve it based on what
the companies tell them 1971 I said
genex has nothing to do with cancer it
has to do with trans-fats hitter cyclic
means acrylamide inflammation from
eating things like deli slices sandwich
meats sausage ham bacon Bologna salami
pastrami pepperoni jerky carne spam and
everybody laughed at me in 1971 well
here the World Health Organization came
out in October 2015
not the FDA not any medical association
of any state or nationally the World
Health Organization came out they called
me from England and they told me doc
where do you see your newspapers on
Monday the World Health Organization's
agreeing with you
what you said in 71 the World Health
Organization now says that eating these
types of processed meats are as great a
threat or greater for trading cancer as
smoking two packs of cigarettes today
are working in an asbestos environment
you will be burying your children if you
let them eat that stuff
and so Time magazine says report links
meat with cancer that's not true it's
processed meats all 20 the top longevity
cultures in the world according to
National Geographic and Pasteur if it's
okay I'm gonna go to 12:30 is that okay
okay our meat eaters there's not a
single vegetarian or vegan bunch of the
top 20 longevity groups or cultures
according to the National Geographic not
me I'm just reporting what they say so
let's get rid of this they're never
gonna find a cure for cancer looking
where they're looking because they're
looking at genetics oh I went too fast
it's gonna kind of do this let me share
with you that you can prevent cancer in
your family very simple don't eat into
the bad stuff take all the 90 essential
nutrients give just be like that baby
Huey group give your body everything it
needs to maximize your defenses against
horrible diseases this was the first
attempt at had
prevention for universities got together
and gave people who they felt were high
risk of having cancer long term studying
they gave them 200 micrograms of
selenium about 1/5 of a milligram very
small amount they couldn't get it
published in medical journals even
though it showed that you could reduce
your risk of colon cancer by 95% by
supplementing with selenium your risk of
prostate cancer guys by 69 percent
reduced risk of breast cancer ladies
depending on whose daddy you looked at
anywhere from 32 to 82% and the medical
journals didn't want to publish it so
they got a potion Popular Mechanics
magazine in April of 1912 well in 1998
the University of Arizona did the same
study the same number of people got
exactly the same result got it published
in annals of Medicine which is a very
famous medical journal now high fiber
diets don't cut colon cancer that's a
failed theory this particular thing this
is a Harvard Nurses Health Study 90,000
nurses over 20 years the University of
South Carolina was given the piece to
look at how the percentages of breast
cancer diagnosis varied depending on how
women cooked their food they
particularly looked at how women cook
their meat they found out and this is
published they said if you cook your
meat very well-done where the fat is
brown or burnt increase your risk of
breast cancer ladies by 462 percent
which means you're going to get it the
figure is in the last C the third
sentence from the bottom in the second
from the right column there says four
hundred and sixty two percent increase
in breast cancer if you cook your meat
well-done if you cook your meat
medium-rare reduce your risk of breast
cancer by four hundred and sixty two
percent that's a nine hundred point
difference between your going to get it
and you don't have to handle it ladies
never never never never eat anything
cooked well done
okay again mammograms let's say for
every hundreds that are found to be
positive mammograms did you say oh you
got a highly suspicious thing you
probably have breast cancer 61% are
false positives but doctor she's gonna
run you through the biopsies and
chemotherapy and radiation remove your
breasts and when they send your breast
they just amputated to the lab they say
well she didn't have breast cancer
oh no let's go have a martini
everything's fine there's my favorite
highway billboard hot dogs cause butt
cancer I'm about sixes these in the
Beltway around Chicago and they're
talking directly to little kids because
what does grandma feed the kid on the
weekend and microwave popcorn and Oreo
cookies BAM they're dead Gen X have
nothing to with cancer arsenic which we
known to be an essential nutrient since
1947 in one type of leukemia acute
promyelocytic leukemia which kills you
in six months they did a big say this is
a University of New York City big study
and after 10 years is large group of
people who had to keep promyelocytic
leukemia they're still in remission now
wait a minute this is supposed to kill
them in six months they quit the
experiment
well does it go on forever these kid
people are not gonna die now do you
think that they said hey we found a cure
or acute promyelocytic leukemia no well
sort of the rogue the rebel medical
doctors are saying it looks like arsenic
deficiency causes leukemia dementia
remember Alison Rosie's is a physician
cause disease 75% of your brain weight
is the myelin the white matter the brain
which is at 75% of your brain weight the
myelin is in fact 100% cholesterol when
it goes away because you're taking
cholesterol-lowering drugs you're eating
egg beaters instead of eggs you're using
margarine instead of butter you're using
lots of salad dressing because some
hippies said it was good for you you're
gonna get alzheimers disease say
physician cause disease
paster dementia this causes the blood
vessels in your brain or plugged from
the same thing to plug your arteries in
your heart
Korsakoff syndrome is a deficiency of a
single vitamin Warneke korsakoff's is a
deficient that vitamin + ms mixed in
there with it i made 12 deficiency
dementia is self-explanatory Hillary
said Alzheimers is an irreversible
progressive brain to start with no known
cause prevention or cure I will spend 2
billion dollars a year of your tax money
to find a cure well in actuality you can
prevent it by 78% right now double-blind
randomized study by Johns Hopkins you
guys ever here at Johns Hopkins you're
kind of neighbors with those guys right
Baltimore Maryland very well-respected
medical school they did the research on
5,000 people 10 years half of them 2,500
got a supplement 2500 you haven't got a
dummy pill and the ones that had the
supplement guess what had 78 percent
less after 10 years had 70% less
al-harazi's this is my favorite
Alzheimers story in the newspaper
mother and son share the bonds of love
and Alison Rosie's he's 52 years old he
has Alison Rosie's as his mother of 82
she has Al's her disease they're both on
the same statin drugs to lower
cholesterol they're both in the same
facility nursing home their doctors are
the same guy who wrote them both the
same prescriptions for Santa and he owns
the nursing home somebody needs to go to
jail what would happen to a politician
what would happen to the mayor of your
city would give all of the contracts for
construction and maintenance and work to
his brother-in-law without throwing out
a bid you'd impeach him wouldn't you
he'd be out right away but doctors get
away with this all the time this is what
made my audio cassette tape in 1991 so
controversial vitamin e can ease memory
loss Allison was patients you can take
someone who's advanced alessandra Z's
came a large dose of vitamin E within
three months he'll be able to find their
way back home you take them around the
block spin them around they can find the
way back home they can cook simple meals
and dress themselves or before they just
sit there like
just with one vitamin this is a news
release on this story from Johns Hopkins
it started two years later after that
study on vitamin E which was published
in 1992 two years later in 1994 Johns
Hopkins set up this experiment and they
just added vitamin C to the vitamin E
said well maybe we can maybe we can
actually prevent it now these people
were all the same same religion they ate
the same way they avoided the same food
they're all farmers in the same Valley
so it was about as good of a
double-blind randomized study as you
could get in human beings
he's not like sixteen different
professions different cities and all
that kind of stuff right okay this is
why we have things that are generational
in families it's not genetic gluten
intolerance well T Mobile ok celiac
disease busted celiac disease
appendicitis diverticulitis zero bowel
syndrome inflammatory bowel disease
colitis ulcer colitis Crohn's disease
asthma bronchitis other respiratory
almost like pneumonia a winter eczema
rosacea dermatitis psoriasis infertility
miscarriages if you have any one of
these things you don't need to go any
further your you have a gluten
intolerance gluten intolerance causes
all these things because these are all
caused by nutritional deficiencies now
there's 900 different nutritional
deficiency diseases you can get all of
them you have gluten intolerance and
here's why on your left on that a is a
cut through the small intestine of a
healthy one-year-old rat you can see the
finger-like villi increases the
absorptive surface your intestines by
95% on the middle photo micrograph see
there you can see where they've lost 50%
of those villi look at all the scar
tissue in there they were on a gluten
high gluten diet for six months the ones
on your right in an e we're on a high
gluten diet for a year 95% of those
villi are gone look at all that scar
tissue how do you get vitamins and
minerals through that stuff you can't
your gluten free diet for kids under the
age of 10
and very rapidly about two to four weeks
you're gonna see a magic thing it's a
god thing I mean just like pastor creflo
dollar's daughter and two weeks time she
was cured we put on a gluten-free diet
as well as supplemented her her
intestines heal not at all it might take
you six to eight weeks before you see
something dramatic it might take two or
three months for a kid under the age of
10 to go from where you're 95 percent is
scarred up back to a normal healthy
intestine our age 50 60 70 80 years of
age it might take you a year to get
totally healed but you'll see something
remarkable in four to six eight weeks
some of the people I've worked with okay
Glenn Frey died at age 67 from
ulcerative colitis again a gluten
intolerance she got to stay off of
gluten stay away from the bad stuff
these three Elvis Presley Michael
Jackson Karen Carpenter all died from
gluten intolerance secondary effects
Michael Jackson had vitiligo he had lost
his skins pigment and that's not his
hair it's a wig his hair was snow-white
he shaved his head and and I had a wig
on all the time because his hair was
white and the skin was white he didn't
bleach himself he he just didn't have
any skin pigment because he couldn't
absorb the minerals that required to
make skin pigment Elvis Presley died
according muppet a heart attack while
he's on the toilet trying to force a
bowel movement through when he was
constipated and Pam he died and Karen
Carpenter was legendary for having hiral
bowel syndrome
this'll you see on your left here was
born to a mother who was 28 years old
she had three miscarriages or you know
the problem she had she had eggs them
all over her face she had constipation
she had asthma and we put her on a
gluten-free diet she was breastfeeding
you see he was three months old
the pediatrician told her to clip his
fingernails put mittens on his hands
that wouldn't scratch himself gave her a
a hydrocortisone cream to rub on him so
he would niche told her to keep
breastfeeding him because it was the
best milk for her never told her to get
off of gluten we got on a gluten-free
diet got around the 90 and two weeks
later her asthma was gone her eczema was
gone the chief had for 28 years and you
see the same thing
her breasts Melissa's total food his
asthma and eggs moving away in two weeks
and here he is on your right two years
later fully tears old now he is totally
perfectly free of all that stuff and
he'll go on to live to be 100 years old
and so on
we see a lot of kids from Southeast Asia
and we have offices and warehouses in
Singapore so we serve everybody except
the North Koreans and maybe they need
the stuff maybe nice people you know who
knows I don't know but you can see on
the left here where they have eczema
they get psoriasis you put him on a
gluten-free diet you get him on the 90
and within weeks it's all back to normal
I have more kids with the same problem
this lady had the psoriasis for 23 years
her dermatologist made three million
dollars treating her with UV light
treatment every week for 23 years
somebody needs to go to jail
we put her on a gluten-free diet cutter
in the 90 cents of nutrients and in 90
days was all gone after 23 years of
suffering according to Forbes magazine
this is March of 2011 the average
lifespan of billionaires is 66 the
average lifespan of billionaires is 66
that's because they used the same
personal trainers that professional
athletes use BAM they're dead they are
the most expensive laboratory animals
ever
I wonder what Steve Jobs his parents
thought when they buried him at age 56
I wonder what satoru iwata CEO of
Nintendo another billionaire who died at
age 55 I wonder what his parents thought
when they buried him at age 55
I wonder what Vice President Joe Biden
thought when they buried his son Beau
Biden age 46 I wonder what the king of
Dubai felt like when his son Sheikh
Rashid died at age 33 you ever caught
him up with a heart attack while he was
running I wonder what former President
Jimmy Carter felt when his grandson
Jeremy died at age 28 from a
cardiomyopathy heart attack
I wonder what Pastor Rick Warren felt
like when his son died at age 27 from
suicide are you getting the picture here
now we as God's children have a huge
responsibility to our children who are
also God's children
if we do not supplement them you will be
burying them that's just the way it is
these are the four books you need to
digest and read for longevity every
black child in the world needs to read
this book black gene lies remember was
paid for by pastor dollar epigenetics
the death of the Genk threesies
transmission in mortality tells you
everything the top 20 longevity cultures
do to live longer than us they have 40
times 100 as we do they have 100 over
252 population we only have one per
10,000 they don't have doctors they
don't have roads they don't have
hospitals or clinics no pharmaceuticals
they have no health insurance and yet
they have 40 times 100 as we do the
whole stories in that book and mortality
rares Ben cures is where those duck
experiments for the for the epigenetics
duck experiment was published and all
kinds of stuff you'll need to know we
think something is pretty good when
somebody lives be 102 107 didn't God say
the man all of men and women 120 our
average lifespan we take both men and
women at 74 that's almost 50 years shark
which look at the language on the
national Geographics here on the
right-hand cover the left-hand cover
this baby will live to 120 in the middle
one this baby could live be 142 years
old russian-georgian a little brown baby
on your left is from the neckline
peninsula in Costa Rica Central America
and the little one on the right from
Russia and Georgia again in addition to
being the Garden of Eden I've been there
twice with the military there is such a
place
the first MapQuest is in the Old
Testament the Garden Eden is east of
Eden and there's four rivers that jump
into that valley Euphrates Tigris Pichon
Deshawn rivers that valley is still
there the river still dumped into that
valley and then there's a land flowing
with milk and honey which is a month
horseback ride or Trek from Jerusalem to
land flowing with milk and honey
certainly within the biblical range of
location is called Hunza the Hunza
Valley 13,000 foot elevation these are
the longest people on earth or a third
world culture and the the gilt star
glacier which is a mile wide the water
that comes out from underneath it looks
like milk it because it grinds up
limestone at 13,000 foot elevation which
is suspended in the water it looks like
milk coming out from underneath the
glacier they have more species of wild
bees and more wild honey than anyplace
else in the world because bees like
minerals the land flowing with milk and
honey these are the longest of people on
earth is documented by everybody
including the National Geographic
this gal here's the lead singer in a
rock group in Okinawa she's 97 years old
look at her energy for 97 this fella
here li ching-yuen I was born in 1677
died in 1933 his obituary is full of
bitumen in the book rare Sven cures was
also in the London Times in the and the
New York Times he died at 256 this is
documented when he was 50 years old he
got a certificate from the Emperor of
China because he was very old back then
back then the average life was like in
their 20s and so to live and be 50 was
outrageous and then when he was a
hundred they gave him another
certificate 150 came in another
certificate was 200 game another
certificate was joiner 50 gave another
certificate
now there's a whole university in the
place where he lived all they do is
study longevity may have all his
certificates hang on the wall may been
tested to show that they are the age of
the day that they are dated okay we're
down to the last say ten minutes here 10
15 minutes our body requires you've
heard me say this a couple of times our
bodies require essential nutrients we
call 90 for life 60 minerals 16 vitamins
12 amino acids 3 fatty acids and this is
what your genes your DNA or RNA in your
telomeres a little end caps in your
chromosomes require to maximize your
genetic potential for fitness and
longevity in health and making good
decisions and strength and speed and all
the things we have tribute to you know
to genetics your body needs these things
an optimal amounts if they're missing
even 10% you're going to get a horrible
disease if they're missing totally
you're gonna die if any one of them is
missing totally it will die if an der
Holyfield if your boxing fan you know he
had a a heart attack cut him out of a
heart attack right in the middle of a
boxing match with Michael Moore
championship fight
I'm the guy that rebuilt him okay with
the 90 essential nutrients plus the
secret sauce for the heart
cardiomyopathy heart disease Keshawn
disease right son even death syndrome
and we were able to rebuild him he came
back and box for eight more years at the
championship level Danny Glover had to
give up action movies because he had
back problems and hip problems we
rebuilt him
90 essential nutrients and the secret
sauce for supporting promoting maintance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue disks between
vertebrae and so on bone matrix and now
he's back doing action movies I spent a
lot of time with pant boone he is a
extremely godly man I just love him he
actually sang some songs to be in his
living room wonderful guy and he was
reduced to selling walk-in bathtubs
because he couldn't do anything because
the back and hip and knee problems well
now you don't see him selling bathtubs
anymore he's back on the road Willie
Nelson's on the road again because he
had to quit for many years because he
had arthritis in his fingers I was able
to rebuild him Drew Pearson the Hail
Mary pass receiver from the Dallas
Cowboys rebuilt his back in hips and
knees now he's one of our top of so she
is working with youngevity you come to
our event she'll meet him with a
fabulous guy you've seen that so I want
to go into that again this is my son's
favorite picture and sees because coming
from the roosting area in the jungles in
the Amazon to eating the clay on their
way out to find bugs and nuts and things
to eat they're getting the minerals from
the clay that's why they're so brightly
colored if you want your pet macaws and
parrots and parakeets to be really
brightly colored you give them our
minerals as well as the seeds they give
you at the pet store in that study idea
with Marlon Perkins 20,000 Sumi 20,000
autopsies we eliminated over 900
different diseases using the information
from those 20,000 autopsies we tripled
the lifespan of animals dogs 60 years
ago live me an average to eight now
they're living 25 eliminate every birth
defects you can name in ten times that
many you can't and so I began to use it
in people and they fired me from Yerkes
when I discovered the cause French and
cure of city of roses I went back to
school became a physician and I began to
use everything I had learned on animals
my human patient that guess what it
works it works because all vertebrates
are God's creatures right and so the
same thing works for a turtle in a
crocodile and a giraffe and an elephant
in a parakeet and a flamingo
just like you and me we need these basic
things God got a good pattern and he
used the same pattern over and over and
over even an oak tree requires genes and
DNA to transfer information through the
Acorn to the baby oak trees now how did
rich people get their minerals well
pharaohs and kings and successful
generals and successful merchants would
pay grave robbers great sums of money
and silver and gold to bring them
mummies they'd grind up the mummies and
used the mummy dust as a condiment like
salt and pepper and their food and yes
what they were healthier than the trolls
living under the bridge were just eating
corn because they were getting their
minerals now obviously poor people and
slaves couldn't can do that so how did
poor people and slaves get their
minerals well the common fuel of the day
back 5,000 years ago the universal fuel
around the world even though people
could not communicate ones living out in
the Pacific Islands and ones living in
Africa couldn't communicate the ones in
North America and so forth in South
America the Aztecs but the common fuel
around the world was wood and what did
they do with the wood ashes every
morning they throw them in the and the
recycling bin to save the earth no they
threw them out in the garden well it
turns out that wood ashes are not ashes
95 to 90% of the wood answers minerals
that the trees sucked up out of the
ground and the plants that you fertilize
with the wood ashes actually sucked up
the minerals and so you ate these plants
out of the garden and you were getting
the minerals from the way nobody knew
that nobody knows it now you're knowing
something only God knows and now you've
been given the information you need to
use it wisely know that remained the
same for thousands and thousands of
years until 3 o'clock in the afternoon
Monday September 4th 1882 on Pearl
Street in New York City on the bluff
overlooking and construction of Brooklyn
Bridge this fellow here Thomas Edison
pulled the switch in the first
commercial electric generating plant
then 10 years every town every
municipality every city in the
industrialized world converted from wood
is universal fuel to electricity
now how many wood ashes are left over in
your home every morning when you when
you fuel your home electricity none zero
now because nobody knew that was your
source of nutritional minerals nobody
supplemented here comes the government
here comes the doctors ojz
you're gonna be everything you need BAM
you're dead now people liked electricity
did it again it'll switch it among
people like electricity and so
politicians jumped in you vote for me
I'm going to put up a hydroelectric
plant we're gonna have electricity in
this valley they did it for the TVA they
did it in the Colorado River Valley in
the southwestern seven nations and we
electrify these things back in the late
1800s in 1910 the 1920s and people had
jobs there was money everywhere I mean
people were rich and we had factories
and life was booming it was wonderful
but there was unintended consequence how
many ever heard of flood control by
these hydroelectric dams oh oh oh
remember what fertilizes the Garden of
Eden flooding every year by the
tigris-euphrates Pichon Deshawn rivers
when water recedes what does it leave
behind silt mud which has minerals in it
did the farmer push that silt off to the
side before he planted no he plowed in
those metals again year after year after
year
well once we got hydroelectric plans to
make electricity
everybody's happy they had jobs
initially now comes the terrible part no
more mud no more silt after the flood
water recedes because there's no more
floods
so God's plan was interrupted according
to the World Health Organization right
now we have nine hundred and sixty
thousand dams damming up the rivers our
Sol's are depleted our oceans are dying
or oceans are dying yes yes yes remember
I wrote the first paper on a mass
die-off in American pollution so I've
kind of kept track of this over the
years pollution has nothing to do with
the oceans dying is dying but this
doesn't have to do with the pollution
we've cut off the food supply to the
ocean we dammed up all the rivers for
utilities
no more silt going to the ocean no more
algae no more a little plant somewhere
fish no more us so we're growing fish
now in ponds with GMO foods fed to the
fish
whales are starving to death for lack of
food and washing up on the beaches now
sharks are attacking people in places in
every use - can you remember during the
beach boy days and the surfing days
sharks attacking people around Hawaii
Southern California why are they doing
that now what was no fish anymore for
them neat so you look pretty good to
them nutritional minerals did not occur
in a uniform blank around the cross ears
they never did they always they occur
like chocolate and chocolate ice cream
some cases are blessed with a lot some
places are blessed with a few some
places don't have any well the people
who live the longest that's one of their
common features is they have lots of
minerals in their soil their food is
rich with minerals ok last couple of
slides this is what makes youngevity
different this is a compost pile that
has 78 minerals in it all 60 essential
minerals and optimal amounts and this is
the core of everything we do in
youngevity these guys are standing on a
road 3000 feet elevation above sea level
we have a hundred cubic miles of this
stuff we give tours of the place and
we're if nobody else has access to this
this is in perpetuity as long as there's
an earth nobody else will have access to
this place we're the only ones I should
tell you minutes about her she's been
with us for 25 years in April she'll
turn 73 she most people think she's 50
years old she owns quite a few vineyards
she's large as vinter in michigan and
grape vines around the world usually
will give you 50 60 pounds of grapes per
year hers give 250 pounds cuz she's
using these minerals from that compost
pile on her grapes she goes five times a
yield and the Amish use our minerals for
their sweet potato farms they get 12
pound sweet potatoes one sweet potato
can feed a family of five for a week now
our cell is known to be depleted in
mineral since 1936 this was the cause of
the Great Depression and the Dust Bowl
our baby food just came out in April of
2012 our baby foods contained less than
20% of the required minerals and bottoms
necessary for proper development dog
food contains 100% chicken food has 100
sheep pig cow food has 100 sent our
babies grandbabies have less than 20% go
read the mineral content to the baby
formalisms and pharmacies and grocery
stores they have less than 5 min rules
so most of them have only three if you
don't supplement them you'll be burying
them hundred-year study 1914 to 2014
USDA reports that 95 percent of all
Americans are mentally deficient the
minerals in ourselves over the past
hundred years are depleted by 85 percent
if you don't supplement if you don't
supplement your kids you will be burying
them and you'll lose 25 to 50 years off
your life ok getting down to the last
one or two slides here that very quickly
will make it in time ok
second last slide everybody needs in
19th century or so we have a basic
program we call the Healthy Start pack
it contains three products has 245
nutrients in it including all 90
essential nutrients and optimized for
100 pounds of human flesh or a month you
give this to a 50 pound kid it's a 2
month supply
give this to a 30 pound kids to 3 month
supply give this to a 200 pound person
you need two of these for month one 400
pounds of body weight per month we have
secret sauces for over 900 diseases some
secret sauces will work on over 150
diseases and of course we teach you how
the hell that works and so forth and
they're very simple the healthy healthy
weight loss packets are weight loss and
healthy sports package for people who
sweat and work hard physically and we
have the healthy digestive pack and the
healthy brain and heart pack less
self-explanatory the healthy bone and
joint packed healthy blood sugar packet
would you use that far diabetes I mean
this is not very difficult we have all
kinds of products which I'm not going to
visit last slide people always ask me
doc what do you take I've been taking
the 90 cent returns twice a day for 69
years I've been taking the 90 essential
nutrients twice a day for 69 years I
have not been sick in 69 years they hem
into a doctor medical doctor ever I have
never been on a prescription medication
I've never had any surgeries now
everybody can do that
because I'm getting the nutrition that
you would find in the Garden of Eden in
the land flowing with milk and honey
remember your genes or DNA or RNA and
your telomeres require this stuff to do
their job if you were to take dirt from
Texas and dirt from Alberta Canada
because there's you know these were the
oil fields are and saying I'm not gonna
waste my money on oil I don't put dirt
from Texas and dirt from Alberta in
there because everybody's knows there's
oil in there that cargo three hundred
thousand miles by putting dirt in there
no and if you just eat salads with salad
dressings you eat processed meats on
your pizza with a gluten filled crust
and you're eating fat-free milk and
taking statin drugs Alaura cholesterol
and you're eating egg beaters bam bam
bam you're dead okay what you see here
on the picture - about six products say
left about six products out this is a
two-week supply for me I do this twice a
month this is what I take I don't expect
everybody to do this if you just take
the 90 essential nutrients and avoid the
bad stuff you'll add 25 to 50 years your
life but if you want to live to be 120
you got to go a little stronger okay but
take the Healthy Start pack one per
hundred pounds of body weight and
obviously if you have certain diseases
you got to take a secret sauce at least
until the process is healed there goes
away now what we're gonna do and I'm
going to invite pastor up here who was
good tell we're gonna do next here I
know they have plans for it for the next
10-15 minutes or so and then I'm gonna
answer questions for you for about an
hour and we're gonna steer you in the
right direction for individual problems
so if you're interested in that I'll be
back in about 10 15 minutes god bless I
know he loves you god bless you
you